voilà et
et et comme vous le savez nous recevons
cet après-midi monsieur Gabriel Atal
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse pour la présentation des
crédits budgétaires du projet de loi de
finances 2024 pour son ministère je
précise que nous compléterons cette
audition parcelle dans 2 semaines de
Marc fen ministre de l'Agriculture pour
la partie enseignement
agricole monsieur le ministre cette
audition budgétaire est d'autant plus
importante que l'examen des crédits de
la mission enseignement scolaire a été
interrompu à l'Assemblée nationale suite
à la décision de la première ministre
hier soir d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement pour permettre l'adoption
de la seconde partie de ce ce PLF le le
Sénat sera sans doute cette année encore
la seule chambre au sein de laquelle le
budget de l'Éducation nationale sera
intégralement discuté les sommes en jeux
sont pourtant de première importance je
rappelle qu'avec près de 63 milliards
d'euros hors pension et hors
enseignement agricole la mission
enseignement scolaire est l'une des des
plus importantes du budget par rapport à
à 2023 son montant total est en
augmentation de quelques 3,9 milliards
d'euros et Nicolas Braganti me faisait
la remarque tout à l'heure que c'est à
peu près le montant du budget du
ministère de la Culture hor audiovisuel
public lors de votre audition il y a 15
jours sur le déroulement de la rentrée
2023 vous vous félicitiez de disposer
pour de 2024 de de moyens budgétairees
historique et aait souligné la
croissance de 30 % du budget d'éducation
nationale depuis 2017 vous nous aviez
aussi fait part de votre intention de
vous atteler en en priorité à
à à l'élévation du niveau des élèves en
particulier en mathématique et et en
français objectif que nous pouvons
évidemment que partager aussi
pouvez-vous nous présenter monsieur le
le ministre les principal orientation de
de votre budget qui contribueront à
atteindre cet objectif euh en ambitieux
parmi les mesures fortes de la politique
du gouvernant se trouve également le le
pacte enseignant en cette rentrée de
vacances de tous sein disposez-vous de
de chiffres actualisés sur sa mise en
œuvre enfin l'article 53 du du projet de
loi de
finances prévoit de manière assez
étonnante une réforme systémique de
l'école inclusive avec la mise en place
des pôles d'appui à la scolarité les
passes vous savez que la problématique
de de l'école
inclusive particulièrement cher à notre
commission notre collègue Cédric Vial a
eu l'occasion d'évoquer son rapport sur
les Aes dans cette même salle il y a de
semaines pouvez-vous expliciter
aujourd'hui l'objectif poursuivi par les
passes plus précisément en quoi
diffèrent-il des piales les pôles
inclusif d'accompagnement localisé dont
la généralisation à l'ensemble du
territoire date seulement de
2021 je vous invite monsieur le ministre
dans un propos liminire à nous présenter
les grands axes de votre budget après
quoi je céderai la la parole
à nos deux rapporteurs en l'occurrence
JAC grin pour les crédits enseignement
scolair et Yan Chantrel pour ceux de la
jeunesse et de la vie associative et
puis bien sûr ensuite à l'ensemble des
commissaires qui demandera de s'exprimer
enfin monsieur le ministre je rappelle
que cette audition est captée et
diffusée en direct sur le site du Sénat
je vous cède la
parole merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs très
heureux de me retrouver à nouveau devant
vous pour vous présenter le projet de
loi de finances pour 2024 un projet de
budget qui au fond vient répondre à un
triple défi l'élévation du niveau
général vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
Président bâtir une école qui émancipe
et bâtir une école qui rend heureux une
école de l'excellence de la liberté et
du bonheur là où certains et verrant y
verront de grands mots nous y voyons un
cap ambitieux parce qu'il est impératif
de calibrer nos efforts pour être à la
hauteur de l'enjeu et parce que
finalement ces trois objectifs vont les
uns avec les autres on peut pas élever
le niveau si on a trop d'élèves trop
d'enseignants qui sont malheureux à
l'école on peut pas élever le niveau si
les règles ne sont pas respectées à
l'école et si l'autorité du maître
l'autorité du savoir n'est pas respecté
dans nos établissements je suis très
heureux de venir vous présenter ce cap
ambitieux les Français attendent
beaucoup de leur école et c'est une
attente légitime parce que dans une
démocratie c'est d'elle que tout naît et
à quoi tout revient parce que nous avons
le devoir d'assurer la réussite de tous
de garantir à chaque élève une scolarité
sereine et de faire de l'école un lieu
et une condition du bonheur nous devons
être fermes face à tout ce qui pourrait
s'opposer à cet objectif je veux bien
sûr vous parler du harcèlement parce
qu'il est une violence insupportable
parce qu'il est un refus de la
différence parce qu'il fait de l'école
un enfer pour beaucoup d'élèves dans
notre pays le harcèlement doit cesser et
je le crois très profondément un
électrochoc a commencé la récente vague
de libération de la parole autour du du
harcèlement démontre clairement
l'urgence d'agir toujours plus vite
toujours plus fort une page de silence
est en train de se tourner et c'est
maintenant la page de la souffrance qui
doit se tourner mais les mots ne
suffisent plus je le sais et je le redis
on ne lutte pas contre le harcèlement
avec des lettres des discours des
circulaires après le moment des constats
évidemment c'est celui de l'action qui
est particulièrement important le
harcèlement c'est un fléo c'est une
maladie de notre école à toute maladie
il y a d'abord un diagnostic nous devons
mettre l'écoute au cœur de notre
stratégie à partir de demain se tiendra
la journée nationale non au harcèlement
8 millions d'élèves du CE2 à la
terminale se verront proposer un
questionnaire destiné à tenir compte de
leur relation avec les autres élèves
cette écoute permettra d'identifier le
mal d'en mesurer l'ampleur de détecter
les situations pour ne plus les laisser
sans réponse c'est un questionnaire que
nous avons construit avec des
scientifiques avec des professionnels de
la santé mentale de l'enfant du climat
scolaire je pense au professeur Marcel
ruffau docteur Nicole Katheline à Éric
de Barbieux également qui ont contribué
à l'élaboration de ce questionnaire à ce
sujet je veux saluer l'adoption du
député balanan dans le cadre de not
débat à l'Assemblée nationale c'est vrai
monsieur le Président qu'il y a eu un
493 mais à la différence de l'année
dernière la mission enseignement
scolaire a pu commencer à être débattu à
l'Assemblée nationale on progresse donc
du point de vue de l'éducation nationale
et cet amendement Balanant a permis
d'ajouter 30 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui viendront renforcer
les moyens de la lutte contre le
harcèlement je suis heureux de notre
capacité commune en tant que responsable
politique à trouver un accord aussi
large que possible sur des projets de
long terme dans l'intérêt du pays et de
sa jeunesse vous le voyez beaucoup de
d'actions on été mis en œuvre mais
beaucoup restent à faire j'en suis
conscient l'objectif c'est de faire le
maximum pour ne plus passer à côté
d'enfants qui souffrent car au fond ce
qui se joue c'est notre capacité à
répondre à ce droit au bonheur et à ce
droit de pouvoir étudier dans des
conditions sereines à l'école mesdames
et messieurs nous sommes réunis cet
après-midi pour examiner le budget 2024
consacré à l'enseignement scolaire qui
traduit l'engagement sans faille du
gouvernement en faveur de la réussite et
du bien-être de tous les élèves
rappelons-le depuis 2017 le gouvernement
a remis l'éducation au cœur de son
projet le budget 2024 du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
s'élèvera cette année à
63,4 milliards d'euros c'est 15
milliards d'euros de plus qu'en 2017 une
hausse spectaculaire de presque 30 %
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président en 5 ans alors même que nous
avons perdu 300000 élève du fait de la
démographie on sait que l'État est
capable de porter des projets de très
long terme en matière de politique
industrielle ou de gestion de sa dette
il doit en être absolument de même pour
l'éducation qui doit se penser en terme
décennal parce que l'avenir de notre
pays ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
c'est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui de
notre école ce budget veut envoyer un
message fort de reconnaissance et de
gratitude à tous nos professeurs car ce
sont eux qui font l'école en
transmettant les valeurs de la
République et en formant les citoyens de
demain c'est pourquoi nous avons donc
porter des revalorisations inédites et
surtout inconditionnelles j'insiste sur
ce point de 125 à 250 € net de plus par
mois par rapport à la rentrée 2022
c'était une promesse de la campagne du
président de la République tous les
professeurs débuteront désormais leur
carrière avec une rémunération de 2000 €
net mensuel après titularisation à leur
titularisation cette cette rémunération
s'élèvera à 2100 € dans l'enseignement
public et même à 2466 € dans les REP
plus on va donc au-delà de Lang pris par
le Président de la République pendant sa
campagne sur la rémunération en début de
carrière entre la réélection du
président de la République en avril 2022
et le mois de janvier 2024 vous savez
qu'au début du mois de janvier
interviendra la mesure transversale
fonction publique de l'injection de 5
points d'indice majoré pour tous les
fonctionnaires nous aurons revalorisé
tous les professeurs de 11 % en moyenne
c'est cet effort budgétaire historique
que traduit ce PLF 2024 je ne doute pas
que vous saurez mesurer la portée de cet
effort inédit pour notre école et pour
la tout entière des revalorisations
nécessaires que monsieur le rapporteur
grosérin avait d'ailleurs appelé de ses
vœux lors du précédent projet de loi de
finances dans le prolongement des
dédoublements déjà mis en œuvre nous
poursuivons avec détermination notre
politique de réduction de la taille des
classes notamment pour les élèves les
plus défavorisés car des classes moins
chargées c'est un meilleur encadrement
plus de temps consacré à chaque enfant
et Infiné de meilleurs apprentissages
dès la rentrée 2024 le dédoublement des
classes de grandes section de maternelle
CP et CE1 sera achevé dans les réseaux
d'éducation prioritaire au bénéfice de
500000 élèves avec un investissement
colossal de 11000 créations de poste de
professeurs des écoles toutes ces
mesures ont déjà commencé de produire
leurs résultats une étude de septembre
2021 de la Direction de l'évaluation de
la prospective et de la performance
montrait ainsi que le dédoublement
permettait de réduire de 15 à 40 %
l'écart de niveau en calcul et en
lecture entre les élèves de REP plus et
les les élèves hors éducation
prioritaire ce PLF finance également la
création de 60 très petites sections
supplémentaires accueillant dès 2 ans en
quartier prioritaire de la politique de
la ville par ailleurs je rappelle que le
plafonnement à 24 élèves euh dans les
classes de CP et de CE1 à comptter de la
rentrée de 2020 continue euh de
s'appliquer il faut maintenant
poursuivre cette dynamique très positive
d'amélioration du taux d'encadrement
dans le 1emer degré et lestendre au
secondaire et surtout au collège
c'est cela même la promesse républicaine
une école qui n'oublie et n'abandonne
personne sur le bord du chemin ce budget
traduit également notre engagement
indéffectible en faveur de la réussite
de tous les élèves parce que la promesse
républicaine de l'école pour tous ne
sera pleinement tenue que lorsque la
réussite de chaque enfant quelle que
soit son origine sociale deviendra une
réalité favoriser la réussite de tous
les élèves c'est aussi poursuivre notre
engagement en faveur de l'école
inclusive vous m'avez interrogé
également sur ce point monsieur le
Président cela commence par une
véritable prise en compte des situations
de handicap en milieu ordinaire depuis
2017 le nombre d'élèves en situation de
handicap accueilli en milieu ordinaire a
progressé de 49 % en cette rentrée ce
sont donc plus de 475000 élèves en
situation de handicap qui sont
accueillis en milieu ordinaire nous
poursuivons sur cette lancée en
recrutant 4800 aesh de plus l'an
prochain à la fin de l'année 2024 c'est
15000 AES de plus qu'en 2022 qui
accompagneront nos enfants pour les
aider à gagner en autonomie dans leurs
apprentissages en quelques années les
aesh sont devenus par leur nombre le
deuxème métier de l'éducation nationale
parce que nous reconnaissons leur rôle
essentiel dans le service public de
l'école inclusive nous avons revalorisé
leur salaire en cette rentrée c'est
entre 90 € nets par mois de plus pour un
aesh débutant et 100 € net de plus par
mois pour un aesh avec 5 ans
d'ancienneté entre août 2021 et janvier
2024 la rémunération des aesh aura
progressé de 26 % en moyenne soit un peu
plus de 200 100 € par mois et cet
automne tous les aesh toutes les aesh
plutôt puisqu'il s'agit beaucoup de
femmes recevront une prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat pour
faire face à l'inflation qui s'élèvera à
500 € en moyenne ensuite nous avons
ouvert vous le savez la possibilité
d'être en CDI à l'issu d'une première
période de 3 ans pour fidéliser et
capitaliser sur l'expérience et le
savoir-faire de ces professionnels c'est
un succès puisque nous avons aujourd'hui
plus de 58 % des aesh en CDI il n'était
que 20 % l'an passé et je rappelle en
2017 quand le président de la République
a été élu les aesh étaient en contrat
aidé c'est-à-dire en contrat précaire
nous avons assez largement commencé à
déprécariser le statut des aesh mais il
faut évidemment continuer nous allons
continuer dans cette voie de la
professionnalisation et de
l'amélioration des conditions de
rémunération en permettant à celles et
ceux qui le souhaitent d'augmenter leur
temps de travail et donc leur
rémunération je sais que le sénateur
Vial il sera sensible et je tiens ici à
saluer tout son travail sur l'école
inclusive au-delà de la Conférence
nationale du handicap
qui a adressé des perspectives
ambitieuses pour améliorer la qualité de
l'accueil des élèves en situation de
handicap je réponds à votre question
donc sur les pôles d'appui à la
scolarité c'est l'article 53 ils se
déploieront progressivement à comptter
de la rentrée scolaire prochaine d'abord
dans trois départements préfigurateurs
ce sont ainsi s pôle d'appui à la
scolarité qu'il est proposé de créer à
la rentrée prochaine en remplacement des
fameux pial pôle inclusive
d'accompagnement localisé je sais que
cet article suscite des questionnements
et parfois des inquiétude et je voudrais
tenter de répondre à certaines d'entre
elles dès à présent j'ai rappelé les
moyens très substantiels consacrés à
l'école inclusive de l'ordre de 4
milliards et demi d'euros l'an prochain
et une cible de 140000 à soit 15000 de
plus qu'en 2022 nous allons continuer à
recruter des moyens humains
suppémentaires pour que les besoins
d'accompagnement humain reconnus par les
MDPH soient satisfaits mais à côté du
nombre et du quantitatif il nous faut
avancer vers le
qualitatif je veux insister sur les
moyens très substantiels dont seront
assortis les passes 100 ETP du côté de
l'éducation nationale un par pass et 200
ETP du côté du médico-social de par pass
à la rentrée prochaine 3000 et 6000 ETP
en plus en
2026-227 en supprimant cet article je le
dis on prend le risque de perdre 9000
ETP comment penser qu'avec 9000 ETP en
plus on fera moins bien que ce que font
les piales aujourd'hui sans moyens
spécifiques dédiés au-delà de la
question des moyens le déploiement
progressif des passes permet des
évolutions qui j'en suis sincèrement
persuadé vont dans le bon sens d'abord
apporter une réponse plus rapide et plus
qualitative aux élèves en situation de
handicap mais également aux élèves à
besoin éducatif particulier concrètement
ce que permettront les passes c'est une
réponse de premier niveau les passes
seront compétents pour la mise à
disposition de matériel pédagogique
adapté d'adaptation pédagogique et de
personnels médicau-sociaux sans attendre
la notification
MDPH deuxème objectif accompagner les
familles dans leur démarche en
particulier pour celles qui souhaitent
formuler une demande de compensation
auprès de la MDPH car je veux le dire
très clairement la création des passes
n'empêchera jamais les familles de se
tourner vers les MDPH au contraire non
seulement les familles auront toujours
la possibilité de saisir la MDPH mais
mieux elles pourront être accompagnées
dans leur démarche ce qui est loin
d'être toujours le cas aujourd'hui par
ailleurs les compétences d'évaluation
des besoins par les MDPH ne sont
aucunement remises en cause enfin
troisème objectif de ces passes
renforcer la coopération entre
l'éducation nationale et le secteur
médico-social c'est le sens des
personnels médicos-sociaux qui seront
mis à disposition des passes c'est
également le sens de la mesure de la
Conférence nationale du handicap qui
vise à créer 100 établissement et
structur médico-sociales dans les murs
de l'école à horizon 2027 en commençant
par 10 à la rentrée prochaine notre
objectif est clair avec cette
transformation faire un véritable saut
qualitatif pour l'accueil et la prise en
charge des élèves en situation de
handicap sans perdre de vue l'objectif
de leur faire accéder à toujours plus
d'autonomie l'objectif c'est de passer
d'un système ststème de gestion on va
dire administrative et RH de personnel
aesh à un vrai pôle d'accompagnement des
familles dans leur démarche vis-àvis de
la MDPH et d'accompagnement des
enseignants et des professionnels avec
l'apport de personnel du médico-social
en soutien de nos enseignants je pense
que c'est très largement attendu sur le
terrain mesdames et messieurs c'est au
cœur de ma feuille de route l'école de
la République ne peut tolérer qu'un
destin soit fixé dès les premiers pas je
le crois très profondément à l'école on
n'érite pas d'un destin on se forge un
avenir l'école doit pouvoir casser le
plafond de verre des origines sociales
l'école doit être un générateur de
possible pour tous nos élèves la
promesse de l'école est incompatible
avec les fatalismes et les inégalités de
destin car sans l'égalité la promesse de
l'école est vide sans cette justice
sociale notre engagement est 20
aujourd'hui 1 million et demi de
collégiens et lycéens reçoivent une
bourse sur critères sociaux que nous
avons réhaussé de 6 % en 2 ans dès la
rentrée 2024 et c'est aussi permis par
ce PLF ces aides seront automatiquement
versé pour contrer les nonreours et les
réflexes d'autocensure par ailleurs
j'ajoute que 150000 élèves obtiennent
une bourse au mérite et 40000 une prime
d'internat autant de dispositifs que
nous entendons péreniser avec ce budget
les fonds sociaux sont sanctuarisés à
hauteur de 54 millions d'euros et nous
poursuivons le déploiement des
petits-djeunés gratuits et des cantines
à 1 € grâce au Pacte des solidarités
financé par la Mission solidarité
insertion du PLF ça ne se voit pas dans
la mission budgétaire dont on est en
train de parler mais c'est là et c'est
pour nos élèves dans nos écoles ces 13
millions de petits déjeunés gratuits que
nous avons pu donner l'an passé aux
élèves de famille modeste on le sait un
élève qui démarre sa journée à l'école
le ventre vide apprend moins bien et
moins concentré et plus dissipé qu'un
élève qui la démarre le ventre plein
j'en suis convaincu et je l'ai dit dès
ma prise de fonction en juillet dernier
l'émancipation des élèves passe aussi et
peut-être d'abord par la culture la
culture à l'école c'est une fenêtre
ouverte sur l'émancipation et aussi je
le dis sur les savoirs fondamentaux dès
cette rentrée le passeculture est étendu
et c'est nouveau dans ce budget au 6e et
au 5e je passe ici je parle ici du
passeculture collectif et non pas du
passculture individuelle à 18 ans l'an
dernier déjà 2,2 millions de collégiens
ont pu bénéficier du passeculture
collectif visiter des musées voir des
pièces de théâtre pratiquer un
instrument 87 % des collèges sont déjà
engagés dans cette voie tout cela
concrétise l'ambition 100 % éducation
artistique et culturelle du président de
la République l'égalité des chances la
promesse d'un avenir ouvert le refus de
toute prédestination sociale voilà une
promesse que nous voulons honorer c'est
dans cette perspective que nous avons
engagé une réforme profonde du lycée
professionnel parce que la voie
professionnelle est une voix
d'excellence au même titre que la voie
générale parce que le savoir technique
ne vaut pas moins que le savoir
académique classique parce qu'il n'y a
pas de hiérarchie entre théorie et
pratique et que tous les deux sont des
chemins de réussite et d'excellence nous
savons le taux de décrochage scolire
dans ces filières est important il nous
faut les redynamiser en permettant
d'augmenter significativement le taux de
poursuite d'études dans le supérieur et
en permettant une insertion
professionnelle stable et durable c'est
pourquoi nous allons investir à terme 1
milliard d'euros supplémentair par an
pour les élèves du lycée professionnel
concrètement cela signifie la
gratification des stages de la classe de
seconde à celle de terminal des
effectifs réduits dans les classes de
nouvelles options qui seront proposées
un bureau dédié aux entreprises sera
créé dans chaque établissement et nous
transformerons en profondeur la carte
des formations mesdames et messieurs
l'école républicaine ce n'est pas que
des beaux principes c'est aussi un
endroit concret un endroit où l'on vit
où l'on travaille notre devoir est
d'améliorer les conditions du bien-être
de nos élèves et de nos personnels je
veux parler plus précisément de la
rénovation du bâti scolaire qui
représente la moitié du patrimoine
immobilier public en France cette
rénovation est cruciale pour que les
élèves puissent apprendre dans les
meilleures condition condition poss
possible c'est un enjeu de justice
sociale tous les élèves quel que soit
leur territoire doivent bénéficier
d'équipements scolaires de qualité grâce
au Fonds vert et au programme du renve
de la Caisse des Dépôts nous allons
rénover 40000 écoles en 10 ans c'est le
plus grand plan de rénovation scolaire
jamais décidé dans notre pays à Mayot
par exemple nous avons vu des résultats
spectaculaires ces dernières années en
matière de savoir fondamentaux nous
allons amplifier notre notre effort pour
le bâti scolaire avec 523 millions
d'euros engagé entre 2024 et 2027 pour
le bâti scolaire afin d'offrir aux
élèves Maoris des conditions d'études
décentes à la Réunion 60 millions
d'euros financeront entre 2024 et 2028
la construction du lycée de la mer et du
tourisme vert qui formera les
professionnels de demain dans ses
filières d'avenir en métropole 96
millions d'euros sont prévus en 2024
pour rénover notre patrimoine immobilier
j'insiste sur ce point là aussi ces
crédits supplémentaires ne sont pas dans
le budget de l'Éducation nationale ils
sont dans le budget de l'écologie
puisqu'ils sont dans le fond vert mais
c'est 500 millions d'euros par an de
plus 500 millions du fond vert qui
seront dédiés à la rénovation du bâti
scolaire de nos écoles pour leur
isolation thermique de la même manière
que nousous sommes aussi engagés dans un
vaste plan
d'équipement sportif pour nos
établissement scolaires ça va de la
rénovation de la cour de récréation pour
permettre un parcours sportif au sein de
la cour jusqu'à jusqu'au gymnase de
l'établissement scolaire euh c'est un
plan d'ampleur qu'a présenté le
président de la République de la même
manière les crédits de ce plan ne sont
pas dans le budget de l'Éducation
nationale mais dans le budget du
ministère des Sports et c'est 100
millions d'euros par an sur 3 ans donc
j'insiste là-dessus parce que entre ce
qu'il y a dans la mission insertion
solidarité mission sport et la mission
transition écologique tout ça ce sont
des crédits aussi pour l'éducation pour
nos élèves pour nos enseignants pour
tous nos personnels et donc c'est
important d'avoir cette vision
global voilà Mesdames et Messieurs ce
que permettra de financer le PLF 2024
pour moderniser notre école et servir au
mieux nos élèves et notre jeunesse je
termine sur une question que vous m'avez
posée monsieur le Président sur le pacte
euh enseignant nous sommes encore en
train d'avoir les dernières remontées ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que nous
sommes désormais au-delà euh du quart
d'enseignants qui s'est inscrit dans le
pacte nous sommes à 37 % au collège 32 %
au lycée général et technologique 45 %
en lycée professionnel cela représente
au total 200000 plus de 200000
professeurs
je veux insister sur un point puisque je
crois qu'on en avait parlé dans la
précédente audition le taux d'adhésion
ne montre aucune déformation selon le
genre et nous voyons qu'il s'agisse du
1er degré ou du second degré il y a une
équivalence entre les hommes et les
femmes qui signent le pacte c'était
important de le dire puisque je sais que
c'était une inquiétude qui était
exprimée évidemment je respecte
totalement cette inquiétude qui a été
exprimée mais c'est important d'y
répondre insiste aussi sur le fait que
le remplacement de courte durée reste la
première mission choisie c'est très
important pour moi vous savez que j'en
ai fixé j'ai fixé un très grand objectif
qui est de limiter au maximum les
absences évitables et de remplacer au
maximum les absences qui ne peuvent être
évitées avec les euh pactes qui ont été
signés autour du remplacement de courte
durée c'est près de 2 millions d'heures
de remplacement en plus qui vont pouvoir
être assurés au bénéfice de nos élèves
dans nos établissements euh cette année
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs je crois que
ce budget est en cohérence avec notre
boussole investir pour nos élèves pour
nos enseignants pour l'avenir de notre
pays une école où la transmission des
savoirs rime avec épanouissement une
école où la réussite de tous passe avant
les déterminismes une école de
l'excellence pour tous cette ambition
doit nous réunir par-delà les divisions
parce que la volonté de remettre notre
jeunesse au centre du jeu est trop
importante pour céder au fracture et
parce que nous faisons de notre école
aujourd'hui un projet qui déterminera
celui de notre pays demain et je me
tiens à votre disposition pour répondre
à vos questions merci Monsieur le
Ministre alors les premières questions V
être posées par nos rapporteurs Jacques
grerin d'abord et ensuite Yan
Chantrel merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues alors vous avez pris le temps
au préalable de de poser le le problème
du harcèlement et notre collègue anè sen
vous a interroger lors des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement moi je
voudrais en préalable de ce PLF dire
deux choses et vous souir sur deux
points
la première c'est le fait que vous ayez
engagé une procédure disciplinaire
vis-à-vis d'une une ancienne rectrice
donc je sais pas comment ça peut aboutir
mais je crois que c'est important parce
que c'est un symbole et puis je pense
que les personnes les parents attendent
cela même si on pouvait s'interroger sur
les conditions de changement de décret
des règles du décret pour cette rctrice
comme quoi elle avait été souvenez-vous
nommée rctrice la plus grande académie
de France de Versailles en changeant le
décret comme quoi lorsqu'on change des
choses souvent ça se termine souvent mal
et le deuxème point je voudrais aussi
vous soutenir vis-à-vis des attaques
récurrentes à votre endroit euh je pense
d'un individu qui est méprisable je dis
le mot méprisable et que nous condamnons
tous en tout cas par les différents
types de propos ob qui peut avoir et il
est important de le dire aujourd'hui en
en amont de cette de cette intervention
monsieur le ministre je tiens à saluer
donc ce budget en haut c'est l'ambition
que vous y porter pour notre école est
élevée nous pourvons qui
souscrire vous avez fait référence
jusqu'en 2 17 par rapport au budget de
l'année dernière c'est plus 3,9
milliards et je crois que c'est
important j'aurai trois questions et
trois questions qui seront nature à
rassurer je eng grs parce que ça
permettra à chacun de pouvoir intervenir
et je crois que chacun a des domaines de
compétences différentes vis-à-vis de
cela la première question c'est quel est
l'avenir du fond de soutien au
développement des activités
périscolaires vous nous aviez indiqué il
y a 15 jours qu'une réflexion é en cours
pour peut-être faire évoluer son
périmètre l'article 54 du PLF prévoit la
suppression de ce fond il n'a pu être
examiné en séance à l'Assemblée
nationale j'aimerais connaître votre
position sur ce sujet en sachant que ce
matin la commission de finances du Sénat
adopté un amendement de suppression de
cet article vous nous avez parlé tout à
l'heure du milliard d'euros lycée
professionnel moi je voudrais vous
demander quel va être le devenir des
deux amendements dans le cadre du
493 les 10 millions d'euros pour l'aide
au lycéen professionnel donc qui a été
voté à l'Assemblée national et les 30
millions pour la revalorisation des
infirmières scolaires est-ce qu'ils sont
repris par
votre gouvernement en tout cas par votre
ministère dans le cadre du texte qui
sera transmis au Sénat car on sait que
le 493 donc va agir à ce niveau-là ma
deuxème question porte sur le pacte vous
avez répondu en grande partie les
auditions que j'ai mené ont mis en avant
qu'il existe des établissement où aucune
brique de pque n'a été prise par les
enseignants ils sont certainement moins
nombreux qu'au 15 septembre ou près d'un
établissement sur tro était dans cette
situation mais il y en avait néanmoins
dès lors comment seront mises en œuvre
dans ces établissements les mesures
Phard de votre ministère concernant
devoir fait ou encore l'accompagnement
des élèves de 6e an mathématique en
français ces Briges du pacte peuvent
être réalisé par des enseignants du
1emer degré et on s'en félicite parce
qu'il n'avaient pas justement l'occasion
de pouvoir eux faire des heures
supplémentaires et je peux ne pas
m'empêcher de penser à ce que je défends
depuis des années sur cette forme
d'école du socle qui me paraît tellement
importante dans le contexte actuel se
pose la question de la sécurisation des
établissements scolaires vous avez lancé
une enquête auprès des établissements
pour connaître leurs problèmes de
sécurité disposez-vous de premiers
éléments des crédits supplémentaires
seront-ils prévus pour les sécuriser et
accompagner les collectivités
territoriales dans cette démarche qui
sont bien sûr partiese prenantes de ces
établissements et je finirai mes propos
par deux remarques alors que l'un de vos
prédécesseurs avait comme objectif
l'école de la confiance il existe
aujourd'hui une défiance forte et
certaine de la part des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale envers leur
ministère il me semble primordial re
bâtir cette confiance car ces personnels
de direction ne doivent pas ne doivent
pas être oubliés leur rôle est essentiel
leur tâche de plus en plus lourd et ses
postes attirent de moins en moins on l'a
vu dans les concours c'est certes une
question de revalorisation sociale mais
c'est aussi d'accompagnement dans la
prise de poste orors les nouveaux
personnels de direction commencent leur
carrière dans des établissements de
catégorie 1 de petits établissements
ruraux où ils peuvent se sentir seuls je
vous remercie yen Chantrel pour les
crédits jeunesse et vie associative oui
merci Monsieur le le président monsieur
le ministre donc j'aurai plusieurs
questions en lien avec ces crédits tout
d'abord maises mes premières questions
ortte sur le le dé déploiement du
service national universel le SNU alors
j'ai une forme d'interrogation sur la
pertinence d'une nouvelle montée en
charge du dispositif puisque les
objectifs pour 2023 n'ont pas été
atteints ne le sont pas d'ailleurs à à
chaque année puisque c'est 62 %
seulement d'objectifs atteints pour pour
cette année avec 40000 volontaires ayant
effectué leur séjour de cohésion donc
malgré ces résultats qui sont décevants
envisagez-vous toujours euh la
généralisation du SNU et si oui à quel
horizon et par ailleurs vous avez
annoncé en en septembre dernier la mise
en place euh en classe de seconde d'un
St obligatoire de de 2 semaines auquel
pourra se substituer au choix la
réalisation d'un séjour de cohésion
justement du SNU pourriez-vous nous
donner davantage de précision sur cette
nouvelle mesure et comment s'articulera
tel avec le label classe et lycée engagé
lancé également en en juin dernier en
outre à travers les les
auditions diverses auditions il y a
nombreux acteurs du tourisme associatif
notamment les les les plus les plus
petits qui bénéficient d'un modèle
économique qui est fondé sur une
complémentarité d'activité entre accueil
pendant les vacances et classe de
découverte euh de mi-février à à la fin
juin or le coût des classes de
découverte on ont explosé ça a explosé
ces dernières années en raison bien sûr
du coût du transport mais aussi des
séjours les centres d'accueil faisant
face eux-mêmes avec l'inflation à une
forte augmentation de leur cût et
d'ailleurs il est il est très difficile
de disposer de chiffres sur
l'évolution de ces classes des classes
de découverte donc PZ pourriez-vous
faire un point sur le nombre de classes
de de découverte en France depuis 10 ans
puisque les classes de découvertees
quand même constituent un outil majeur
d'apprentissage de promotion aussi du
vivre ensemble que que que vous plaidez
et de construction de l'enfant qu'il
faut absolument valoriser donc quelle
mesure envisagez-vous pour
faciliter l'organisation justement de de
ces séjours et soutenir les centre
d'accueil face à l'explosion de leur
coût enfin je je souhaite également vous
alerter sur la situation du monde
associatif toujours dans ce contexte
inflationniste qui inquiète fortement
les acteurs du du secteur alors même que
les effets des des vagues épidémiques
successives se font encore ressentir euh
en 2000 en 2023 les associations font
également euh nous ont fait état d'une
mutation aussi du profil des bénévoles
avec notamment un recul important au
niveau de la proportion des seniors qui
sont engagés euh dans nos associations
et une transformation des des formes
d'engagement caractérisé par un
bénévolat plus ponctuel donc le tissu
associatif local en est fortement
fragilisé et doit plus que jamais être
soutenu donc quel méc mécanisme
allez-vous mettre en place pour
accompagner les associations face à ces
problématiques je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre je
vais vous laisser répondre aux questions
des
rapporteurs merci monsieur le Président
je vais répondre aux différents points
monsieur le rapporteur gros Perin vous
m'avez interrogé sur le fsdap le fond de
de développement des activités
périscolaires alors ce que j'ai fait
c'est que j'ai pris un arrêté déjà pour
rétablir les montants 2022 en 2023 pour
cette année pour revenir sur la décision
qui avait été prise donc pas de
changement cette année ensuite vous
l'avez dit l'article 54 du PLF
prévoyait oui prévoyait la suppression à
compté de 2024 du fond ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que l'article 54 du PLF
ne prévoit plus cette suppression
puisque dans le 493 le gouvernement a
retenu un amendement de suppression de
cette mesure donc on revient sur un
statut quo en
revanche l'amendement qui a été retenu
déplace à 2025 la suppression de ce fond
donc en fait ça supprime pour 2024 mais
ça déplace à 2025 d'ici à ce qu'on ait
une concertation avec les collectivités
locales sur l'avenir de ce fond je
rappelle pas puisquon beaucoup parlé
dans la précédente audition les tenants
et les aboutissant qui avait conduit à
prendre cette décision mais voilà en
tout cas pas de changement cette année
pas de changement l'an prochain et donc
une concertation pour prévoir pour 2025
la manière dont les choses pourraient
s'appliquer je précise que c'est
l'article de lettre qui a changé mais
que du coup il y aura peut-être une
coordination à faire sur les crédits
puisque par définition les crédits
avaient été ajustés en fonction de de de
ce qui était prévu c'est-à-dire la
suppression du fond sur les autres
amendements sur lesquels vous m'avez
interrogé euh je crois que c'était sur
notamment l'aide au permis de conduire
pour les lycéens professionnels je crois
pas que cet amendement été retenu
puisque comme je l'avais indiqué en
séance ces crédits doivent être pris et
il y aura un amendement pour abonder le
budget du ministère du Travail et non
pas celui de l'éducation pour l'aide au
permis de conduire pour les lycéens pro
puisque comme c'est déjà sur le budget
du ministère du Travail que que sont
pris les crédits pour l'aide au permis
de conduire pour les apprentis en il a
été décidé de tout mettre sur le budget
du ministère du Travail donc et le
dernier point vous m'avez interrogé sur
un amendement sur la médecine scolaire
en l'occurrence sur les infirmières
scolaires et effectivement il y a un
amendement qui avait été porté par le
groupe Renaissance et le groupe
socialiste qui avait été
adopté en séance il n'a pas été retenu
par la première enfin par le le
gouvernement par le gouvernement dans le
493 voilà par contre on a par
contre non non mais je voilà j'avais
donné l'avis du gouvernement qui était
défavor able j'avais bien dit donner la
relayer l'avis arbitré du gouvernement
en séance ça avait été adopté malgré cet
avis et il n'a pas été retenu en
revanche a été retenu l'amendement qui
prévoit 30 millions d'euros
supplémentaires je ai parlé tout à
l'heure pour la lutte contre le
harcèlement qui va nous permettre
notamment d'avoir des équipes
académiques de lutte contre le
harcèlement parce que on voit
qu'aujourd'hui le trou dans la raquette
c'est quand vous avez des situations qui
ne se gèrent pas au sein de
l'établissement et que ça part en
conflit entre l'établissement la famille
là il faut qu'on ait des tiers de
confiance qui puisse venir dans
l'établissement au contraire épayiser le
dossier pour trouver une solution et
donc c'est pour ça moi je veux vraiment
qu'il y a des personnes dédiées à 100 %
au harcèlement dans chaque rectorat
aujourd'hui il y a des poste de référent
mais en général c'est avec autre chose
ils ont pas toujours le temps là ça sera
des gens 100 % dédiés à ça je veux que
ça soit aussi des personnes qui viennent
pour certaines de l'éducation national
mais pour d'autres d'autres sphères pour
apporter aussi une culture nouvelle sur
la gestion du harcèlement dans
l'éducation nationale donc ça pour le
coup c'est et ça permettra aussi pardon
des rémunérations supplémentaires pour
des enseignants ou des personn personnel
qui s'engagent comme référents
harcèlement dans leur établissement avec
ces 30 millions ça ça c'est retenu
sur pardon les deux autres points que
vous avez évoqué devoir fait et
accompagnement des élèves oui c'est
réalisé par des pactes de professeurs
des écoles un sur 6 adhérer au Pact
aujourd'hui dans les écoles dans le
premier degré mais c'est aussi effectué
de voir fait par des heures
supplémentaires classiques qui demeure
le PCT n'a pas supprimé les dispositifs
de HSE ou autres qui existent et donc
vous vous avez des enseignants qui
peuvent continuer à faire dev voir fait
continuer à faire du remplacement de
courte durée sans pass sans avoir adhéré
au Pact mais par des heures
supplémentaires c'est la même chose ils
sont juste moins payés donc c'est vrai
qu'on peut enfin s'interroger sur
pourquoi à ce moment-là ne pas basculer
dans le PACT c'est un choix individuel
mais quand vous faites du remplacement
de courte durée en heure supplémentaire
vous êtes payé 42 € de l'heure quand
vous faites le même remplacement de
courte durée dans le cadre du PACT
enseignant vous êtes payé 69 € de
l'heure et donc voilà vous pouvez
continuer à le faire sans Pact enfin sur
la sécurité des établissements
euh j'ai fait le point avec les
associations d'élus lundi matin encore
on a investi budget état 170 millions
d'euros depuis 2017 pour la sécurisation
des établissements alors même je le
rappelle que ça n'est pas la compétence
direct de l'État à ce stade il y a 10
millions d'euros prévus dans le PLF 2024
c'est dans le budget dans la mission
administration générale et territoriale
de l'État et dans la ligne FIPD si ça
vous intéressait d'aller regarder euh on
a formé aussi beaucoup 14000 personnels
de direction l'enjeu j'ai lancé une
enquête flash c'est qu'on voit bien que
un collège lycée sur 4 n'a pas de
dispositif d'alerte quand il y a une
intrusion dans l'établissement il y a eu
beaucoup de débats par voie de presse
ces derniers temps sur la sécurisation
des établissement est-ce qu'il faut des
portiques des tourniquets des SAS des
caméras des voilà moi je considère que
ça n'est pas notre rôle depuis Paris de
prescrire la manière dont un
établissement doit être sécurisé ne
serait-ce que parce que quand on est
pragmatique on voit voit bien que tous
les établissements sont différents et
que ça aurait pas de sens d'avoir un
seul modèle en revanche il me semble on
devrait tendre quand même vers 100 %
d'établissements qui ont une alarme
spécifique quand il y a une intrusion
dans l'établissement parce que l'alarme
spécifique 1 elle permet à tout le monde
de comprendre que c'est une intrusion et
que donc à la différence de l'alarme
incendie vous devez pas tous sortir de
votre classe mais plutôt tous y rester
et vous confiner et de il faut que cette
alarme permette de alerter
automatiquement les forces de sécurité
ce qui n'est quasiment jamais le cas
aujourd'hui donc là-dessus il faut qu'on
puisse avancer avec les élus évidemment
je suis conscient qu'il y a certaines
collectivités notamment les plus petites
pour lesquelles c'est compliqué de payer
un dispositif d'alarme c'est là où les
crédits du FIPD peuvent venir soutenir
les collectivités locales enfin dernier
point sur la confiance dans
l'institution je vous rejoins totalement
je crois que le CNR est aussi en train
de contribuer à changer ça ça se fait
progressivement mais on a là des projets
qui sont portés par des équipe sur le
terrain qui bénéficie de financement
pour le pour se déployer et à côté de ça
des équipes du ministère de
l'administration qui ne viennent plus
que en contrôleur mais en facilitateur
en accompagnateur pour ces projets et
sur les personnel de direction
spécifiquement je vous rejoins
totalement depuis des années on leur
demande toujours plus c'est beaucoup de
pression c'est beaucoup de missions
supplémentaires ils sont en première
ligne sur des enjeux extrêmement
sensibles le harcèlement on en a parlé
la laïcité on l'a encore vu avec
l'interdiction de laaba c'est eux qui
étaient en première ligne sur beaucoup
de sujets les personnels de direction
sont en première ligne et j'oublie pas
euh leurs adjoints je n'oublie pas les
CPE qui sont aussi très mobilisés j'ai
ouvert un chantier spécifique à la
rémunération des personnels de direction
avec eux et je souhaite qu'on puisse
avancer d'ici au début de l'année 2024
pour prendre des décisions monsieur
chanrel sur le SNU euh donc les
objectifs du SNU c'est 40000 volontaires
en 2023 et effectivement on vise un
doublement à 80000 en 2024 en s'appuyant
notamment sur les classes et lycées
engagés vous l'avez dit 160 millions
d'euros sont prévus au PLF 2024 je
précise que ça n'est pas dans cette
mission budgétaire c'est dans la mission
jeunesse vie
associative et ma collègue ma collègue
prisec TV qui est secrétaire d'État
auprès de moi est totalement disponible
pour répondre à plus de questions il y
aura quatre sessions et quatre
thématiques d'engagement sport et Jeux
Olympiques défense et mémoire
environnement ou résilience et
prévention des risques sur la
généralisation du SNU moi j'ai toujours
dit que j'ai étais favorable il faudra
une loi et donc je peux difficilement
vous dire aujourd'hui à quelle date ça
deviendrait généralisé obligatoire pour
tout le monde en tout cas à titre
personnel j'y suis favorable sur le
stage de seconde du 17 au 28 juin oui
c'est une nouveauté j'ai affirmé mon
objectif de reconquête du mois de juin
c'est pour ça que j'ai décalé les
épreuves de spécialité du baccalauréat
de mars à juin c'est pour ça que j'ai
concentré les épreuves le plus possible
vers la fin du mois de juin ce qui nous
permet de garantir que les deux
premières semaines de juin il y a cours
pour tout le monde c'est pour ça que
j'ai décidé de mettre pour la première
fois les épreuves du brevet des collèges
en juillet pour que tous nos collégiens
soient dans leur collège et en cours
jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin je me
suis pas fait que des amis chez les
élèves mais ça me semble important et
effectivement quand on regarde le mois
de juin tous les lycéens seront en cours
la première quinzaine dans la deuxième
quinzaine les premières et terminales
partiront en épreuve et pour les élèves
de seconde il y aura un stage de 2
semaines si on regarde tous les pays qui
réussissent mieux que nous en matière
d'orientation exemple Suède Pays-Bas ou
autres ils ont tous beaucoup plus de
stages que nous y compris dans la voix
générale et technologique et donc moi je
on peut pas en rester avec juste le
stage de de 3e donc là ce stage de de 15
jours pour les fins de secondes je pense
sera très utile il va nécessiter de
mobilisation collective mais j'ai j'ai
pu voir que l'Association des régions de
France et et beaucoup de présidents de
région qui demandaient un stage de de
fin de seconde ont dit qu'il se
mobiliseraiit à fond qui mobiliseraiit
leur secteur économique j'ai échangé
avec et je continue à le faire à
travailler avec des fédérations du
patronat de secteur économique des
filières professionnelles pour mobiliser
pour proposer des terrains de stage et
j'ajoute que évidemment tous les élus
toutes les administrations on aura aussi
cette responsabilité d'accueillir des
stagiaires en en fin juin pour pour la
seconde
euh si un élève réalise son SNU à ce
moment-là effectivement il sera exempté
de stagees de la même manière que pour
ceux qui font des qui s'engagent dans
des dispositifs de mobilité
internationale euh ils en seront
exemptés aussi euh et pour ils sont
encore assez peu nombreux à cet âge-là
mais je le précise parce que la question
m'a été posée pour des jeunes qui ont
déjà un peu un job d'été et cetera
évidemment ça vaudra exemption du stage
ça va de soi
euh sur les associations là c'est pareil
c'est pas dans cette mission mais je
vous réponds quand même augmentation en
2024 du budget du fdva de 50 à 70
millions d'euros en révisant dans ce PLF
l'article 272 de la loi de financeces
pour 2020 qui permettait d'affecter 20 %
des avoirs détenus sur les comptes dit
inactifs acquis par l'État à destination
des associations locales par amendement
gouvernemental au PLF qui a été adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale et retenu
évidemment dans le 4 33 nous avons fait
progresser ce taux à 40
% l'augmentation du fdva va permettre de
toucher de soutenir le maillage
associatif de proximité davantage je
rappelle que le fdva bénéficie
aujourd'hui à plus de 17700 associations
don 80 % sont des petites
structures voilà monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur ministre pour ses
réponses on enchaîne
avec l'ensemble des questions que vous
souhaitez poser en commençant par Max
Brisson monsieur le ministre je voudrais
d'abord vous faire partager la
difficulté d'être sénateur cette
semaine je vais devoir aller rejoindre
assez vite l'hémicycle je ne pourrais
peut-être pas écouter votre réponse je
sais capitement votre règle de ne pas
répondre aux sénateurs au sénatrices qui
sont absents et vous avez raison je vous
demanderai exceptionnellement une
indulgence parce que finalement je pense
que ma présence est nécessaire si j'en
juge par les SMS que je reçois pour
aller défendre les positions de votre
collègue le ministre de l'Intérieur
je sais pas si c'est un argument
monsieur le
sénateur je voudrais aussi monsieur le
ministre vous remercier pour la qualité
de l'échange que vous avez eu tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle avec AG
Sévin sur la question du harcèlement et
je rejoins cela ce qu'a dit très
fortement notre collègue et rapporteur
Jacob cérin moi aussi je veux saluer
votre engagement très noble très fort
très personnel et très et que nous
soutenons pleinement sur ce sujet vous
vous savez que vous pvez compte sur le
Sénat revenons au budget il est en
hausse historiqueavez-vous dit je j'ai
une interrogation je deme si ce
budget traduit vraiment votre ambition
réformatrice que je ne conteste pas
ou ce contente-t-il d'accompagner les
mouvements lancés par vos
prédécesseurs présenter un budget c'est
l'occasion de passer des bas paroles aux
actes alors de toute évidence et on le
reconnaît ce budget injecte des millions
supplémentaires mais ce budget
engage-t-il des réformes en profondeur
ainsi concernant les enseignants au-delà
des nécessaires revalorisations qui
figurent dans le budget allez-vous
dissocier la formation de ceux du 1er et
du second degré comm induirit la
création des écoles norm mal du 21e
siècle que vous avez annoncé le F les
ferez-vous échapper ces écoles normales
à la tutelle des universités comment
entendez-vous accompagner l'entrée dans
le métier moment crucial de la carrière
et mettre un terme au bisutage
institutionnel des néo titulaires
comment allez-vous créer des postes à
profil et des contrats de mission pour
que les carrières soient moins linéaires
comment allez-vous prendre en
considération les second carrière
comment avec un nombre de contractuels
croissant votre budget prévoit-il pour
eux une vraie politique de formation de
suivi et d'accompagnement bref comment
ces évolutions nécessaires de la gestion
des ressources humaines se tratuit-elle
dans votre PLF au-delà des
revalorisations nécessaires ensuite vous
le savez nous sommes par attentifs au
dynamique
d'égalité d'accès à l'école sur les
territoires ruraux alors note avec
précision votre annonce de maintien de
2500 postes que je salue dans un
contexte de baisse du nombre d'élèves
évalué à 500000 entre 2023 et 2027
pourtant chaque année se rejoue le même
scénario entre les élux locaux et
l'éducation nationale quant à
l'affectation des postes d'enseignant et
des fermetures et ouverture de classe ce
fonctionnement est à rebour de la
démarche des élus qui doivent eux
projeter sur plusieurs années des
travaux d'entretien de rénovation et
désormais de transition énergétique au
vu des projections à long terme sur les
effectifs d'enseignants et d'élèves
pouvez-vous nous indiquer si vous allez
approfondir le travail lancé afin de
dégager une vision
pluriannuelle de la carte scolaire enfin
concernant l'évolution pédagogique qui
vous avait été annoncé comme un outil de
transformation majeur du système
éducatif quelle cohérence quelle clarté
quelle transparence allez-vous impulser
entre les ambitions de l'école faisonsla
ensemble et en fond d'innovation
pédagogique car est la traduction
financière mais dont la dimension
innovante de beaucoup de projets retenus
ne nous est pas apparu évidente et
au-delà quelle est votre vision de
l'innovation pédagogique enfin sur les
annonces concernant l'école inclusive et
Cédric Vial y reviendra tout à l'heure
ne pensez-vous pas qu'une telle
réorientation par rapport à la loi sur
l'école de la confiance ne méritait-elle
pas autre chose qu'un article dans le
budget dans le projet de loi de finances
n'était-elle pas une loi n'était-ce pas
un vrai projet de loi qui était
nécessaire avec un vrai débat au
Parlement sur le l'importance de ce
sujet de l'école inclusive j'ai laissé
du temps qui pour être mutualisé pour
mes collègues non je je crois que c'est
plutôt l'inverse mais je Marie-Pierre
Monier je vous invite chacun des
orateurs à bien regarder le chronomètre
en même temps c'est un exercice je vais
essayer si si j'ai bien compris je peux
récupérer le temps que Max n'a pas
utilisé sur de alle
oncha monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues d'abord je
va vous parler suppression de postes et
nombre d'élèves par classe ce budget
2024 est marqué par de nouvelles
suppressions de postees 1331 dans le 1er
degré et 680 dans le second dans le
second degré c'est environ 7500 emplois
déjà supprimés pour les exercices de
2018 à 2020 21 alors même que les
effectifs ont enregistré une hausse de
68000 élèves sur cette même période dans
le second degré en ce qui concerne le
premier degré j'ai constaté en Drome les
fermetures de classes conduisant à des
effectifs surchargés le nombre moyen
d'élèves par classe en maternelle orors
REP et REP plus s'élèv à 24,5 élèves par
classe soit de points et demi de plus
que la moyenne nationale c'est beaucoup
trop et ce n'est qu'une moyenne
disposez-vous d'éléments sur le nombre
d'élèves moyens par classe en France
dans le premier degré mais hors classe
dédoublé et pourquoi ne décidez-vous pas
de profiter de l'opportunité
démographique sur la période à venir
pour maintenir le nombre d'enseignants
et améliorer de façon significative le
taux d'encadrement plutôt que de
supprimer des nouveaux postes à
l'occasion du prochain budget vous avez
dit combien peu d'élèves par classe
facilitent les
apprentissages école inclusive donc vous
nous avez expliqué le remplacement des
piales par les passes mettez-vous à la
place des parents et des des enfants à
qui on a expliqué quand les piales ont
été créé que c'était la solution
maintenant vous expliquez que il en faut
une autre et donc en effet j'ai eu des
retours comme d'autres de parents
d'enfants en situation d' handicap qui
sont inquiets en particulier le Conseil
national consultatif des personnes
handicapé a appelé à la réécriture de
cet article ainsi qu'à une véritable
concertation autour de ces nouveaux
pôles d'appui à la
scolarité donc allez-vous engager une
concertation et peut-être revoir votre
position
là-dessus nous pensons pour notre part
que la réponse se trouve dans le
recrutement massif des ESH et
l'amélioration significative de leurs
conditions de travail vous avez bien
parlé de l'augmentation de salaire
qu'ils ont j'aimerais connaître s'il
vous plaît le salaire moyen des As tout
tempant de travail confondu à la suite
des
revalorisations que vous avez misise en
œuvre éducation à la sexualité trois
séances annuelles d'éducation à la vie
sexuelle et affective par an 20 % des
collégiens et 15 % des lycéens les ont
effectivement c'est un rapport de la
Cour des comptes c'est pourtant un outil
indispensable à la fois pour faire
reculer les violences éduquer notre
jeunesse au consentement les préserver
de pratiques à risque et commencer à
déconstruire les stéréotypes de genre 10
associations viennent de sortir ce lundi
un livre blanc sur le sur le sujet pour
que la loi soit enfin réellement
appliquée le Sénat c'est dans le passé
prononcé à faveur d'une haose des moyens
dédiés à ces heures pour qu'elles alent
effectivement mais chaque fois çaétait
supprimé cet ajout à l'Assemblée est-ce
que vous allez pouvoir remédier à cela
et enfin revalorisation force de
constater que la profession enseignante
n'a jamais été suscité aussi peu de
vocation avec 3100 postes qui n'ont pas
été pourvés à l'ESS des concours c'est
vrai vous l'avez dit et c'est vrai qu'il
y a des efforts qui ont fait pour les
salaires en début de carrière mais il
reste bas pour un niveau requis de Bac +
5 la France est en queue de poeloton au
sein des pays d'Europe de l'Ouest par
ailleurs les professeurs euh constatent
qu'ils seront confrontés à milieu de
carrière un nouveau plafond de
rémunération auquel vous avez répondu
seulement par le recours au pacte
enseignant si travailler plus pour
gagner plus j'ai fini vous avez dit
200000 profs mais sur les 854000 ça fait
23 é=% même pas 1/4 et rappelant
rappelons que les enseignants français
ont perdu entre 15 et 25 % de
rémunération au cours des 20 dernières
années je vous remercie anque
billon merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez dit
tous les deux le le budget du ministère
de l'éducation est en forte hausse et
elle ne l'a jamais été autant plus 6
et5i %. impossible de démarrer cette
intervention sans faire écho aux
événements tragiques qui ont touché
l'éducation nationale à la fois le
harcèlement scolaire chers collègues qui
intervenait tout à l'heure en question
d'actualité avec la gravité des
situations et l'obligation de de réussir
à enrayer ce fléo donc évidemment je
salue votre engagement sur le sujet et
la sécurité pour avoir participé dans
des des établissements scolaires oui le
pragmatiste voudrait que chaque
établissement scolaire adapte ses
dispositifs pour pouvoir répondre à ces
situation première question concernant
le pacte enseignant on prend le vers à
moitié plein ou à moitié vide la moitié
quasiment ou la moitié l'ont fait ou
n'ont pas fait donc je voudrais savoir
si vous avez identifié les freins qui
qui font que certains professeurs ne se
sont pas engagés y voyez-vous une
défiance vis-à-vis euh du ministère par
exemple euh comment justifiez-vous ce ce
manque d'adhésion ou euh ce pas assez
d'adhésion ça dépend comment on prend la
question de manière positive ou négative
une deuxième question sur l'augmentation
de la rémunération elle a été historique
vous l'avez rappelé au niveau des des
des professeurs euh malgré cela on
ressent bien une insatisfaction dans les
auditions qui ont peut être menées par
le rapporteur euh du corps enseignant
donc comment l'expliquez-vous et quid de
la revalorisation pour
l'attractivité des personnels de
direction donc qu'est-ce qui est prévu
pour ces personnel de direction puisque
souvent ce sont pas forcément des postes
très attractifs pour les euh c'est
personnel ensuite sur les aesh alors je
reviens sur l'article 53 moi je vais
juste poser une question puisque déjà
plusieurs collègues l'ont l'ont l'ont
pointé du doigt euh le rôle de ces
passes donc ces pôles d'appui à la
scolarité euh en fait ils évalueraient
les besoins des enfant la question qui
est soulevée c'est si l'éducation
nationale a à la fois la mission de
déterminer la quotité horaire des aesh
nécessaire pour un bon accompagnement de
l'enfant et celle de recruter et de
rémunérer ces aesh comment on va pouvoir
s'assurer vous allez pouvoir vous
assurer que ce n'est pas l'offre qui va
déterminer la demande donc quelles sont
les garanties que vous pouvez nous
fournir par rapport à cet article 53 et
je rejoins l'intervention tout à l'heure
de Max Brisson puisque c'est vrai que et
de Marie-Pierre Monier d'ailleurs sur le
le transformation des des piales en
passe j'ai l'impression que on on
modifie très souvent les règles et on
n'attend pas suffisamment de voir
comment ça fonctionne donc n pour avoir
mené des travaux ensemble tous les C
j'attends une réponse de votre part je
rejoindrai aussi la question de
Marie-Pierre Monier en tant que ancienne
présidente de la délégation au droits
des femmes et de la sortie ce livre
blanc cette semaine sur qui a été signé
par une dizaine d'associations on avait
dans le dans un de nos rapport droits
des femmes proposé la désignation d'un
délégué académique à l'éducation à
l'égalité et à la sexualité donc que
pensez-vous de cette proposition et
votre prédécesseur déjà en septembre
2022 euh avait signé une circulaire
visant à la rendre la loi effective donc
nous sommes euh plus loin que la rentrée
très loin de la rentrée 2022 et cette
loi n'est toujours pas appliquée donc
quels sont les moyens que vous allez
mettre en œuvre et quelle articulation
avec les associations peut-être une
dernière question si euh le président me
l'autorise euh ben écoutez juste
peut-être je vais me limiter l'école des
2 ans en Rep avec quel quels moyens euh
à la fois physique et humain matériel et
humain pardon euh pour pouvoir la
garantir je vous remercie monsieur le
Président pour votre indulgence
euh je vais quand même inviter les
orateurs suivants à respecter les 3
minutes parce que sinon on déborde
beaucoup et on a tout Lord Arcos merci
Président je vais essayer de faire mieux
monsieur le ministre merci euh pour
toutes vos explications euh je je
voulais moi revenir sur euh savoir s'il
y avait un budget à louer concernant les
fournitures numériques notamment pour
les communes rurales vous savez qu'ils
ont pas les moyens forcément de de
pouvoir se payer des trau des tableaux
numériques aujourd'hui beaucoup en non
simplement euh on pourrait faire un état
des lieux moi je le vois par exemple
dans mon département ça n'est pas le cas
on a une réunion avec la dazen
dernièrement et l'association des maères
ruraux de de lessonne montré qu'il y
avait encore des communes qui
malheureusement n'arrivaient pas à s'en
doter et donc je sais pas si dans le
budget euh
vous avez pensé parce qu'à une époque
c'était un plan national en fait et ça
avait été inclus dans le budget
concernant alors je vous demandéis à
Cédric Vial s'il a posé la question mais
il m'a il m'a dit qu'on je pouvais lui
poser vous la poser concernant les
conventions sur le péiscolaire entre les
ESH et et le les communes c'est vous qui
les rémunérz mais en fait après vous
envoyez la facture aux communes pour le
périscolaire et je dois dire que ça
passe plutôt mal en tout cas chez moi et
on l'a beaucoup dit pendant la campne
campagne euh c'est compliqué euh pareil
les communes sont à sec et donc euh je
voulais savoir si aussi d'une certaine
manière on ne pourrait pas compléter le
fait que les aesh puissent être
rémunérés par le National mais également
sur le périscolaire sans que on fasse
contribuer certaines communes qui n'en
ont pas les moyens sinon en effet ça
fait un un trou dans la raquette pour
ces enfants qui ont besoin d' accompagn
même au moment de la cantine euh et et
des des activité extrascolaire et puis
dernière dernière chose concernant le
passeculture euh cuit de la formation de
nos professeurs sur le pas culture
mutualisé beaucoup de beaucoup de nos
professeurs sont de bonne volonté mais
n'utilisent pas forcément receverver le
Pass Culture hier en audition euh
beaucoup de professeurs ne savent pas
forcément utiliser ce Pass parce qu'en
fait ils n'ont pas cette culture et
cette formation euh aux EAC et donc je
voulais savoir si là aussi euh il allit
avoir un effort supplémentaire en terme
de formation Gérard
laec merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre rapporter aux
objectifs ambitieux que vous avez
rappelé permettez-moi d'exprimer le
souhait que le débat le plus large
puisse avoir lieu sur ce sujet important
qui est celui de l'éducation certes
votre budget est en progression mais il
convient de mettre cette hausse de 6
et5i% en a raison avec l'expression des
besoins et je voudrais pointer ici le
fait que la croissance en terme de
rémunération de la masse salariale est
imputable beaucoup à la création de ces
postes d'aesh dont il convient me
semble-t-il de vous donner acte même
s'il reste à préciser les modalités de
leur intégration voire de leur
intégration dans la catégorie B de la
fonction publique puisquil m'a semblé
que c'était aussi une revendication qui
avait cours aujourd'hui our en revanche
cette hausse masque la suppression des
2500 postes d'enseignants en 2024 et ça
après 1500 l'année passée enfin l'année
pour cette année alors vous nous
rassurez je sais que en application de
la règle de 3 rapportée à la baisse des
effectifs la
suppression théorique que ceci aurait
engendré su été moin 5000 emplois mais
vous nous dites que malgré tout
ce dispositif ne contrariera pas votre
objectif de préserver je dirais le
dédouble la politique de dédoublement
des classes
d'ACT mais je voudrais y rajouter quand
même le fait que il conviendrait aussi
de faire de la pérénisation des RPI
singulièrement dans nos zones rurales un
objectif important parce que lorsque
ceuxci sont déstabilisés c'est l'offre
éducative qui se trouve ainement
bouleversé en second lieu j'ai lu aussi
attentivement vos déclarations sur le
niveau hétérogène des élèves notamment
en collège et étant un de ces élèves qui
ont connu le
temps privilège de l'âge le temps
précédant le collège unique je dois vous
dire que lorsqueon était en enseignement
court et qu'il s'agissait d'intégrer
derrière l'enseignement long c'était
quand même un sport assez complexe et
nous ne sommes pas nombreux à avoir
réussi cette intégration c'est la raison
pour laquelle je considère que le
collège unique avec ses défauts fut
malgré tout une avancée et qu'il
convient donc de préciser aujourd'hui
les modalités qu'il convient de mettre
en œuvre pour garantir l'offre éducative
si d'aventure demain on bouleversait ce
collège unique qui n'est sûrement pas
sans défaut mais encore faudrait -il par
nous dire par quelle politique la
remplacer
enfin j'ai lu attentivement également
vos déclaration sur le retour aux écoles
normales très bien mais je n'ai pas vu
grand-chose sur la formation des profs
du second degré et donc je sais que ça
suscite aussi beaucoup de débats mais
toute précision utile serapportant à ce
sujet serait la bienvenue merci de votre
attention Monique de Marco
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre d'habitude je suis
courte pu puisqu'on m'accorde 3 minutes
je vais peut-être les utiliser voilà
Monsieur monsieur le ministre le temps
de formation continue des enseignants
est inférieur à la moyenne des pays de
l'OCDE beaucoup d'enseignants
considèrent qu'il n'existe pas de
formation adapté à leurs attentes vous
avez annoncé lors de votre dernière
audition au Sénat une remise à plat une
révision de la formation des enseignants
adapté à la réalité au défi du 21e
siècle quelles dispositions budgétaires
sont prévues parallèlement je poursuis à
la demande du Président de la République
ont lieu actuellement des états généraux
de l'information avec un axe de
réflexion qui est soumis donc dans ces
états généraux qui est l'éducation à
l'information et au
médias et j'ai dernièrement vu un
rapport un rapport d'information
présenté à l'Assemblée nationale
au nom de la délégation aux droits des
enfants ce document juge primordial de
renforcer les facultés de discernement
et d'esprit critique des enfants en
ligne à travers la mise en place d'une
discipline à partentière ou d'heur
dédiées pour apprendre aux jeunes de
trouver leur repère dans la jungle des
réseaux sociaux leur principale source
d'information je vous rappelle que
d'après une étude de l'institut Lipsos
52 % des 16 19 ans utilisent
quotidiennement Instagram pour
s'informer sur l'actualité 47 % TikTok
et 44 % YouTube donc quelle suite
comptez-vous donner aux proposition de
ce rapport de l'Assemblée nationale je
vous
remercie Bernard
fialer merci monsieur le Président moi
avant de commencer je voudrais aussi
remercier le féliciter plutôt le le
ministre pour son intervention sur sur
TF1 l'autre jour parce que on a tous
beaucoup de respect par exemple sur pour
nos enseignants pour leur savoir leur
savoir-faire et leur savoir-être et il
est bien que le le ministre de
l'éducation nationale puisse avoir cette
dignité dont dont on est assez fier pour
pour l'éducation nationale donc merci
moi je voudrais revenir sur le le le SNU
don on sait que vous êtes aussi un des
promoteurs pour vous dire quand même que
on a été invité moi j'ai été invité à
chaque séance de de SNU autour de sur
mon territoire et chaque fois en
interrogeant les les participants aucun
n'avait eu l'information par l'Éducation
nationale aucun ils l'ont tous su par
bouche à oreille par les réseaux sociaux
mais jamais on le en a parlé dans
l'éducation national enfin en tout cas
j'en ai pas rencontré et pourtant les
différents stages que j'ai vu venaient
de toute la France c'est c'est un peu
surprenant la deuxième la question que
jeis aussi vous poser c'est où sont
les élèves qui n'ont pas été admis à la
rentrée après les vacances de la toussin
nous avez dit pour
avoir pour n'avoir pas
respecté la minute de silence en en
hommage au professeur Dominique Bernard
vous nous aviez dit qu'il ne rejoindrait
pas les les établissements est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire ce qu'ils sont
devenus euh trisème petite question
devant les problèmes de recrutement là
qui ont été plusieurs fois abordés euh
moi je soutiens
aussi la promotion d'une école normale 3
ans de formation des maîtres et même
pour dans l'enseignement agricole on
s'aperçoit que le le le problème de
recrutement de techniciens qui peu
spécialisé agricole pose un vrai
problème lorsqu'on exige ces 5 ans alors
je sais qu'il y a des des dérogations
qui sont apportées mais est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui pourra aussi être
étudié globalement dans cette réflexion
sur sur l'enseignement et le recrutement
qui est important qui est nécessaire et
qui manque dans l'enseignement agricole
en particulier donc dans les
enseignements technique et enfin une
petite question sur vous vous dirigez
maintenant le le fameux mamouth dont
certains parlaient auparavant euh je
sais qu'il y a à peu près 11 % de
personnel non enseignant euh dans qui
dépendent de votre ministère j'ai vu
entre autres qu'il y en avait 40 %
euh quand il y a 10 % de de
d'enseignants qui sont en détachement il
y en a 40 % par contre dans les non
enseignants qui sont en détachement
est-ce qu'il y a vraiment un suivi de
tous ces personnels qu'est-ce qu'ils
font est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
un peu merci
adelziane merci président merci monsieur
le ministre de votre retour de votre
visite de votre disponibilité et je
voulais vous le dire aussi comme
l'évoqué mes collègues notre plein
soutien dans la lutte contre le
harcellement scolaire que vous allez
engagé là aussi lors de votre venue il y
a quelques semaines vous aviez évoqué
c'est sur ça que je voulais rebondir on
est en train de parler des effectifs des
suppressions de poste vous aviez déjà
évoqué la la dernière fois qu'en France
il y avait 15 millions d'heures de cours
non dispensé à l'heure actuelle enfin
pour l'année précédente je ne me trompe
pas ce que vous aviez dit et moi ce qui
m'interroge et ça a été évoqué par
Marie-Pierre Monier ma collègue
lorsqu'on a une suppression de 2512
postes évoqués en année N en 2023 on
avait déjà ces 15 millions d'heures non
dispensé euh on explique donc vous nous
expliquez que la baisse des élèves
attendus va être minime elle était de
5000 et elle est attendu je crois à peu
près au même niveau en 2024 j'ai
l'impression est-ce qu'on va pas se
retrouver avec une baisse des effectif
mais également les mêmes difficultés vu
les suppressions de postes qui vont
aboutir aux mêmes conséquences des
heures de cours non dispensées et je le
dis d'autant plus que je l'avais évoqué
la fois précédente euh la scè saintnil
département dont je suis sénateur est un
département où on constate que les
élèves arrivés euh qui arrivent au bac à
18 ans ont déjà une année de cours en
moins dans l'ensemble des matières qui
ont qui ont été dispensés je le dis
d'autant plus que euh des exemples
récents sur le bilan de l'année 2023
c'est pas des cas isolé mais la scè sa
est frappée de ce point de vue-là c'est
des professeurs qui n'ont pas été à date
au mois de mai et c'est la FCPE 93 qui
le faisait remontter des absences de la
mi de mi-sepembre au mois de mai de PR
d'histoire géographie de pre de français
de prof d'espagnol dans des villes
diverses et variées comme le rinc
onousbois Lila l'île Saint-Denis donc
voilà moi je voulais comprendre un petit
peu comment vous voyez justement cette
évolution cette baisse des effectifs
mais cette suppression de poste de
professeur et comment on ne se retrouve
pas dans la même situation nous ne nous
retrouvons pas dans la même situation de
ces 15 millions d'heures de cours non
dispensé deuxième point ça a été
largement évoqué par mes collègues les
aesh cette priorité je constate nous
constatons que 3000 ETPT à vont être
créé en 20 24 euh du côté de la maison
départementale pour les personnes en
situation d'handicap du 93 c'était ce
sont 6700 enfants qui n'étaient qui étai
sans solution adapté dans le département
d'assè saint-is et on estimait cela donc
à 2500 à sache manquant je rebondis sur
ce que disait mon collègue sur la
nécessité de d'avoir une visibilité sur
la répartition à venir de ces de ces
postes qui sont je dis pour mon
département plus seulement une question
de rattrap mais d'inéquité républicaine
pour pouvoir être en capacité justement
d'apporter une réponse adaptée dans dans
les pour les familles qui bien souvent
subissent en tout cas en se une forme de
double peine des difficultés sociales
l'accompagnement d'un off Fran en
situation de handicap et le plus souvent
une exclusion une incapacité à se rendre
dans ces écoles ce qui a abouti à des
situations assez assez compliquées comme
l'année dernière une maman anciine
saintoni qui avait attaqué l'État et qui
avait obtenu gain de cause puisque le
trib tribunal administratif de mon avait
considéré que l'éducation nationale
avait failli en en attribuant pas une
ass à temps complet pour aider son fils
dans son apprentissage voilà les
questions assez concrètes je vous je
voulais vous poser monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie Anne vantalon
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre merci pour la clarté de
votre réponse sur le devenir du
financement des TAP et de votre décision
de suspendre l'arrêté relatif à la
suppression car effectivement les
collectivité local à l'heure de la
préparation du budget communal ont
besoin de visibilité donc les voilà
rassuré en attendant la concertation
pour une évolution en 2025 alors moi je
souhaitais vous interroger sur le
dispositif 30 minutes d'activité
physique quotidienne à l'école bouger
pour mieux apprendre telle était
l'ambition affichée par le gouvernement
lors de la présentation en 2020 alors la
ministre des Sports affirmé en septembre
dernier que seulement 10 à 15 % des
écoles n'avaient pas mise en place la
demi-heure ce chiffre n'est pas confirmé
par l'Union Sportive de l'enseignement
du premer degré ni par les syndicats
enseignants ce dispositif généralisé à
la rentrée de septembre 2022 est
inégalement appliqué car la mesure se
heurte à la réalité du terrain ce
chiffre avancé par la ministre des
Sports ne reflète pas le retour que nous
avons dans nos départements alors
interrogé en avril dernier le ministre
min de l'éducation nationale n'était pas
en mesure de livrer de bilans chiffrés
de l'élargissement de ce dispositif
faute de contrôle et de bilan actualisé
les enseignants s'interrogent alors
Monsieur le Ministre êtes-vous
aujourd'hui en mesure de nous dresser un
bilan chiffré de cette habitude sportive
recommandée je vous remercie colombe
Brusselles merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre tout d'abord je me
félicite du fait que
j'ai la raison et le mot qui me vient
mais il n'est en rien péjoratif mais que
la concertation soit de nouveau à
l'ordre du jour sur l'accompagnement des
activités périscolaires et le fait que
le fond qui était censé disparaître de
façon abrupte et sans concertation soit
de fait maintenu pour l'année prochaine
et que vous engagez ce qui paraît normal
avec les collectivité territoriale
l'avenir de ce fond nous ne serons
peut-être pas d'accord sur les décisions
qui seront prises mais elles seront en
tout cas prises en concertation et je me
félicite que euh voilà la mobilisation
des uns et des autres nous est remis
dans un mode de fonctionnement qui me
paraît normal et et républicain quelques
questions alors euh je je comptais vous
interroger sur euh la non hausse du
budget pour l'année prochaine en matière
de santé scolaire et la façon dont on
pouvait imaginer euh remplir des
objectifs tout à fait primordiaux en
matière d'accompagnement de la santé euh
physique et psychique des élèves sans
augmentation de budget j'ai entendu vous
nous l'avez dit tout à l'heure qu'un
amendement avait été proposé à
l'Assemblée nationale par le groupe
Renaissance qu'il avait eu un un avis
défavorable du gouvernement et puis une
493 a réglé de toute façon la le sujet
si je peux dire les choses trivialement
si j'étais takquine je vous dirais que
vous pouvez tout à fait compter sur la
mobilisation des sénateurs notamment
socialistes pour permettre
l'accompagnement euh de ces besoins
pardon je souris mais le sujet est
extrêmement grave et sérieux on a besoin
ce pays a besoin et les jeunes de ce
pays ont besoin que euh les les moyens
soient à la mesure des difficultés qui
que vivent aujourd'hui les élèves en
matière de santé physique et euh et
psychique et mental et nous serons je
l'espère au rendez-vous parce que c'est
un vrai sujet primordial donc vous
pouvez compter sur nous euh j'avais
envie de vous interroger sur une des
lignes que vous n'avez pas
évoqué et qui
est la question des aides sociales qui
est censé venir en aide aux élèves les
plus en difficulté ce budget est en
baisse l'année prochaine il était d'un
milliard d'euros en 2023 il baisse en
dessous de du milliard d'euros en 2024
et encore plus stupéfiant même si les
montants sont évidemment moindres les
fonds sociaux baisse en 2024 alors
peut-être allez-vous me répondre baisse
démographique très honnêtement je crois
que dans un pays dans lequel on a 1003
de personnes qui sont allées au resto du
cœur l'année dernière enfin cette année
pardon on plus de 60 % des locataires du
parc social qui décent ne pas arriver à
boucler leur fin de mois très
sincèrement faire des économies lorsque
vous vous nous dites que le budget est
en hausse ce qui est vrai euh faire des
économies sur l'accompagnement des
élèves dont la situation des familles en
matière sociale est la plus complexe et
la plus difficile me paraît vraiment pas
être le bon levier d'économie je crois
au contraire qu'on a besoin de
sanctuiriser ces moyens pour permettre à
chaque élève quels que soient les
difficultés matérielles de sa famille de
pouvoir vivre une scolarité la plus
apaisée et puis pardon monsieur le
Président vous avez parlé du passculture
il se trouve que nous avons auditionné
la ministre de la Culture il n a
quelques jours de cela et je m'étais
permis de lui poser la question comment
on fait pour arriver à toucher les 6e et
les 5è avec le passculture collectif ce
qui est une bonne chose avec une
augmentation de budget du passculture
qui est inférieure à l'inflation la
ministre nous avions été nombreux à
poser beaucoup de questions n'avait pas
eu le temps de répondre à cette question
et donc merci d'avoir remis le sujet sur
la table donc je vous pose à vous
finalement la question comment fait-on
avec un budget de fait qui n'augmente
pas pour arriver à toucher tous les
élèves de 6e et de 5
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre exposé
alors il y a effectivement une volonté
légitime dans votre budget de mieux
rémunérer nos enseignants pour répondre
à la question de l'attractivité du du
métier mais l'attractivité du métier ne
se cantonne pas seulement à une question
pécunière les difficultés de recrutement
ne peuvent être aujourd'hui résolu que
par une chose c'est la fin de la crise
d'autorité que traverse actuellement
l'éducation nationale tant que nos
enseignants ne seront pas reconnu et
respecté tant que leur fonction ne sera
pas supérieure à la volonté des parents
voire des enfants d'aller à l'encontre
des valeurs de des principes de la
République et bien aucune revalorisation
ne sera compenser l'ensemble de ce que
la profession a perdu ces dernières
années alors ma question est simple
monsieur le ministre en plus des moyens
mis sur la table pour revaloriser les
salaires de nos enseignants quels moyens
comptez-vous mettre en œuvre afin de
répondre à cette crise d'autorité euh
vous avez parlé des bâtiments euh des
bâtiments scolaires la rénovation des
bâtiments scolaires alors le budget de
l'Éducation nationale au sein du euh du
PLF 2024 connaît pour une 2e année de
suite une belle augmentation en effet
premier budget de l'État celui-ci va
bénéficier d'une hausse historique de
3,9 milliards d'euros soit une
augmentation de 6,5 % par rapport à 2023
pour atteindre 63,6 milliards d'euros
parmi les objectifs justifiant
renforcement des moyens se trouve
l'accueil de tous les enfants à l'école
ainsi que la transition énergétique or
pour remplir ces deux objectifs ce sont
des bâtiments adaptés aux normes
environnemental qui sont nécessaires
ainsi d'ici 10 ans 52000 bâtiments
scolaires sur 52000 et bien 40000 écoles
devraient être rénovées cependant le
coût de cette rénovation qui sera
important pour pour nos collectivités et
notamment pour les plus rurales d'entre
elles n'est pas budgeté dans votre
enveloppe mais dans le fond vert pour
les collectivités monsieur le ministre a
raison de 500 millions d'euros annuels
ce fond sera hautement insuffisant pour
permettre à chaque collectivité de
rénover les bâtiments scolaires qui sont
aujourd'hui bien souvent plus des
passoirs thermiques qu'autre chose alors
ma question est donc simple comment
l'État comp-ils accompagner les
collectivités pour atteindre cet
objectif ambitieux mais ind ensable à
l'éducation de nos enfants et enfin je
vais revenir sur les stages de
seconde fin juin je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous il faut effectivement
que nos enfants que nos élèves fassent
beaucoup plus de stages le problème de
l'avoir placé les 15 derniers jours du
mois de juin et ça ce sont les chefs
d'établissement qui le font remonter
monsieur le ministre c'est qu'on n pas
dans les milieux ruraux les possibilités
de de trouver des entreprises pour
pouvoir les accueillir voilà donc la
question est là qu'est-ce qu'on va
mettre en œuvre et bien pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que ces élèves puissent
être accueillis
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre j'ai trois
thématiques j'essayer d'être bref mais
la pédagogie est une question de
répétition donc je vais revenir sur les
as et sur le le le Pass je pense que
vous avez compris au vu des questions
qui vous ont été posés sur ce sujet les
les lourdes interrogations qu'on se pose
pour ce qui nous paraît sur cette cet
article 53 être un cavalier budgétaire
puisque vous vous prenez prétexte sur un
budget de de presque 4 milliards d'euros
sur le la compagneement enfants en
situation de handicap de de la création
de 100 postes pour faire une réforme
finalement de de l'accompagnement de de
ces enfants qui avaient été elle par
contre introduite par la loi l'école de
la confiance et donc on on trouve que ce
ce ce procédé n'est ne semble pas adapté
euh ça a été redit tout à l'heure sur
les inquiétudes nombreuses que cela pose
et pour lesquelles on a on a pas
vraiment de débat et le PLF ne se
prêtera pas à avoir ces débats sur le la
la gestion par l'Éducation nationale qui
qui de de de ces de ces accompagnements
en lieu et place de la MDPH ce qui éit
une préconisation de de l'inspection
générale de l'éducation mais elle était
la seule à partager cet avis parmi
l'ensemble des acteurs donc on est un
peu déstabilisé que vous ayez retenu
cette cette position et qui va créer une
double situation avec des enfants
reconnus en situation de handicap par
l'Éducation nationale et d'autres qui
leur seront reconnus par les MDPH
puisqu'ils n'interviendront que dans un
certain cas et et et qu'en deuxième
ressort donc on on permet d'attirer
votre attention là-dessus il faudra
qu'on en rediscute le PLF ne s'y prête
pas et donc je pense qu'il faudra
revenir probablement sur cette sur cette
mesure lors des auditions il a été dit
que c'était une expérimentation mais le
texte ne parle pas d'expérimentation
donc vous voulez aussi avoir votre avis
là-dessus est-ce que c'est une
expérimentation finalement ou est-ce que
il faut se fier au texte qui qui nous
est proposé et et enfin euh sur eu
sur sur cette proposition on voit aussi
que les piales fonctionnent bien ou
fonctionnent mieux quand ils sont près
des territoires là vous parlez de 100 po
c'est dire un par département ça veut
dire vous allez créer des passes
départementaux probablement est-ce que
ça vous allez pas à à
contre à contrecourant de de ce qui
fonctionne deuxième question sur le
SNU ça a été dit aussi tout à l'heure
vous avez dit que vous vouliez
généraliser ma question est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut que ce soit
obligatoire ou pas j'ai entendu à deux
reprises votre secrétaire d'État votre
nouvelle secrétaire d'État j'ai entendu
deux versions différentes de euh du du
SNU donc je sais plus trop euh quelle
version il faut il faut croire et enfin
sur le service civique on l'a pas abordé
c'est pourtant un budget important
c'était l'année dernière plus de 500 519
millions plus 200 millions ce qui était
mis sur le plan de relance aujourd'hui
j'ai vu que 519 millions au budget cette
année est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus à la fois sur les objectifs
qui semblent plutôt en retrait par
rapport à ce qui étit fait jusqu'à
présent sur le le nombre de de de
service Civic euh à la fois sur la
partie budgétaire et enfin il y avait
une avance qui avait été faite parce que
des objectifs n'avaient pas été atteints
notamment pendant le covid à la sortie
du covid à l'agence du du service
civique les fonds avaient été versés les
fonds avaient été votés avaient été
versé alors que les services n'avaient
pas été réalisés est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire où est passé cet argent est-ce
que l'État va récupérer cet argent qui
qui était venu gonfler de manière très
forte et très artificiellement le les le
le fond rou ement de de l'agence de
service civique où est passé cet argent
monsieur le ministre et combien vous
allez remettre cette année je vous
remercie David
Ross merci monsieur le Président et
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
patience alors on est un peu long mais
ça montre l'attachement qu'à cette
Commission au plus beau des ministère de
cette république je le dis puisque
l'école c'est je sais pas si c'est un
mamouth mais pour moi c'est la clé de
voûte de la société c'est le lieu
d'apprentissage des jeunes générations
avec apprentissage des savoirs
apprentissage des règles et aussi
apprentissage de l'autonomie et de
l'épanouissement alors évidemment moi je
peux que me féliciter de l'augmentation
du budget de l'Éducation nationale je
vais rejoindre mon collègue Brisson même
si vous verrez que c'est pas les mêmes
attentes et que ça montre la richesse de
cette commission sur le passage du
quantitatif au qualitatif et donc ça
m'intéresse effectivement de vous
puissiez peut-être préciser au regard
peut-être d'ailleurs des répartitions
budgétaires mais l'ambition que vous
partagez dans un certain nombre de
domaines liés à la qualité le premier
aspect c'est les effectifs vous l'avez
évoqué je je vous félicite évidemment
pour tout ce qui est généralisé sur des
classes à24
cpce1 on reste encore avec des effectifs
les plus élevés en Europe par classe et
donc c'est important de poursuivre cet
effort au sein de l'école mais je pense
aussi au niveau des collèges parce que
même dans un territoire comme le mien où
l'IPS est très élevé on voit de plus en
plus des enfants en difficulté en
difficulté scolaire et en difficulté
aussi comportementale donc je vous
rejoins tout à fait sur vos positions de
fermeté que vous avez évoqué que ce soit
au moment évidemment de la minute de
silence pour Domini Bernard ou plus
récemment sur les questions liées au
harcèlement mais attention pour moi la
Phrase ce que vous avez proncé tout à
l'heure que la peur et la honte doit
changer de camp je vous rejoins tout à
fait sur la peur sur la honte je mets un
petit bémol parce que ce sont des
enfants ce sont des adultes qui sont en
formation et donc ça m'intéresserait de
savoir quand vous parlez d'exclusion ce
qui est important dans un premier temps
qu'est-ce qui est fait pour accompagner
ces enfants pour qu'ils prennent
conscience de leur actes ou de leurs
propos et pour qu'il puissent changer
pour qu'ils puissent devenir puisque
c'est l'objectif à terme des adultes
responsables la deuxème question c'est
sur les rythmes d'apprentissage puisque
la dernière fois vous étiez venus vous
aviez répondu quasiment à l'intégralité
des questions sauf à une question que je
avez posé sur non pas le financement du
périscolaire sur les villes qui restent
à 5 matinées travailler mais sur la
position du ministère dans la durée sur
le rythme pédagogique de quatre matinées
ou 5 matinées travaillé est-ce qu'il va
y avoir des évaluations lié aux
expérimentations qui ont été menées
est-ce que vous avez une position sur
cette
questionlà 3è point donc c'est là où je
rejoins la thématique portée par mon
collègue Brisson et alors comme je vais
rester j'espère que j'aurai la réponse
parce que j'aurai la chance entre
guillemets de passer la soirée avec le
ministre d'armanin même si j'avais eu la
liberté de faire le choix j'aurais
peut-être fait un choix différent mais
donc en tout cas j'y serai ce soir mais
je resterai en tout cas avec grand
plaisir pour entendre vos réponses sur
donc le dernier aspect qui est l'aspect
lié à à l'innovation et à la formation
ça a été évoqué par un certain nombre de
mes collègues mais ce qui
m'intéresserait c'est savoir j'ai posé
la même question à la ministre Sylvie
rotaillot hier ici même sur les liens
avec la recherche dans la formation des
enseignants pour les aider dans tout ce
qui est les aspects à la fois sociétaux
technologique et éthique lié à la santé
au climat et au numérique qui englobe
aussi évidemment l'attrait des filières
scientifiques et technologique dont nous
avons besoin pour la suite à travers une
nouvelle génération et qui englobe aussi
la question des nouvelles techniques
numériques qu'utilisent les jeunes pour
apprendre des choses ils estiment que la
vérité effectivement est sur TikTok donc
si évidemment il faut leur apprendre que
c'est pas le il faut peut-être que dans
l'enseignement aussi je voudrais savoir
s'il y a un budget qui est consacré à
cela les enseignants utilisent
finalement aussi ces outils de manière à
faire passer les propres connaissances
qu'il souhaitent faire passer et donc je
vous remercie monsieur le Président deux
derniers intervenants Jean ingret puis
Béatrice gosel biencié alors bien merci
Monsieur le le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais tout d'abord vous
remercier pour ce que vous faites contre
le harcèlement scolaire c'est vrai que
nous avons été profondément ému dans le
département desvuges pour la mort du du
petit Lucas je sais que vous avez eu
encore des des mots sincères et et plein
d'émotion hier soir avec la la première
dame et je voudrais vous en remercier et
vous dire que nous vous attendons de
pieds ferme dans mon département
justement pour une séquence sur ce sujet
en complètement de de tout ce qui a pu
être dit sur le le le harcèlement quel
est votre bilan sur la loi de 2022 sur
le cyberhcèlement est-ce qu'elle vous
permet de lutter efficacement pour pour
éradiquer ce fléau du harcèlement au
niveau scolaire je me permets aussi de
toujours dans les vuches de vous faire
remonter
des des choses du terrain sur des
directeurs d'établissement et des
professeurs qui me disent que de plus en
plus de parents utilise le temps
scolaire pour partir en vacances pour
payer notamment des vacances moins
chères j'aimerais avoir votre position
sur ses parents qui utilise le temps
scolaire pour partir en vacances qui est
tout tout à fait inacceptable les
dernières question très rapidement le
président de la République avait
souhaité planter des armes que chaque
que chaque élève de 6e tout du moins
dans un premier temps puisse planter un
arbre comment votre ministère va pouvoir
aller dans le dans ce sens dans le le
choix et ce qui a voulu le président de
la République pour planter des arbres
avec chaque petit français puisse
planter un arbre je vous
remercie Béatrice goselin
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation très claire oui moi je vais
revenir sur deux sujets trois sujets
enfin deux sujets et un témoignage la
première chose c'est que vous avez parlé
évidemment du nombre d'élèves baisse
dans nos territoires et particulièrement
nos territoires ruraux et que il y a une
amélioration du Tour d'encadrement c'est
vrai mais n nous n'avons pas peu de
classe de dédoublement alors je sais que
c'est réservé au REP mais nous avons et
nous le constatons et les professeurs de
collège nous le disent qu'on le niveau
de de de mat ê français de nos élèves
est en grande difficulté et que je crois
que avoir deux enseignants pour ces pour
ces écoles ces classes primordiales de
d'apprentissage de cpc1 me semble
importante alors quand on a des
diminutions de postes et bien on a des
enseignants pourquoi pas ne garder des
enseignants sur ces classes primordiales
parce que je crois qu'il faut réellement
remettre le français et les maths au
primaires pour qu'ensuite on nit pas ces
difficultés j'avais j'étais lundi dans
dans un collège un lycée et le directeur
me disait que dans les dans les classes
de 10e c'est presque un/ers des enfants
qui ne maîtrisent pas la lecture donc
un/ers des enfants qui ne maîtrisent pas
la lecture on comprend bien que derrière
tous les apprentissages et toutes les
découvertes ne se font pas correctement
donc je crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
qu'on profite et malheureusement de
cette baisse démographique qui existe
pour mettre le paquet excusez-moi sur le
nombre d'enseignants et l'encadrement de
nos primaires ça c'est un premier point
le deuxième il a été développé
excellemment par mon collègue Cédric
Vial et par d'autres c'était cette ce
questionnement entre le passe et le pial
mais surtout tout la la coordination
entre les la MDPH et les et les et les
aesh vous avez largement dit que le
nombre d'Ah allait être augmenté c'est
très bien mais il y a vraiment une
coordination qui n'est pas évidente avec
le monde du médicosocial aussi donc je
crois que c'est vraiment toute cette
articulation qui permettra à nos enfants
d'être le mieux intégrés et d'avoir une
école inclusive telle qu'elle soit et
enfin je voudrais finir par un
témoignage j'étais ce tout à l'heure
avec une professeur d'une d'un lycée du
valdeemarne d'un collège du valdeemarne
qui m'a dit qu'elle est arrivée à la
rentrée avec une professeur qui s'est
suicidé dans l'établissement et je
voulais vous parler du mal-être des
enseignants on a parlé du besoin de nos
enfants d'être bien dans leurs
établissements mais on a réellement et
je rejoins un peu ce que disait madame
berrti tout à l'heure on a réellement
des enseignants qui souffrent euh des
enseignants qui ne comprennent pas leurs
élèves cette professeur qui est qui est
venu me voir me dit moi je voilà je je
fais ce métier depuis 12 ans j'aime mon
métier mais je suis désemparée les
enfants ont aussi parfois chahuté au
moment de l'hommage de Monsieur Bernard
elle a discuté avec eux et dit mais ça
sert à quoi une minute de silence mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que les valeurs de
la République mais nous on est on n'est
pas français et je crois que réellement
réellement on a ce problème dans nos
établissements et et alors c'est pas
bien sûr tous les établissements mais
mais je suis vraiment j'étais vraiment
choquée de ce témoignage en me disant
mais à quelle dans quelle souffrance
sont nos enseignants et pour terminer je
ce directeur que j'ai rencontré lundi me
disait qu'il n jamais vu ses enseignants
aussi fatigués un jour de rentrée de
novembre ça veut dire qu'ils ont fait 2
mois des classes et qu'ils sont épuisés
donc il y a réellement je crois qu'on
parlait de la rémunération de nos
enseignants et c'est très bien qu'elle
soit revalorisée mais le problème est
beaucoup plus important et ce malaise il
faut vraiment qu'on arrive à le à le
résoudre parce que c'est vraiment ces
enseignants cette professeur me disait
moi je crois que je vais arrêter
l'enseignement alors qu'elle adore ce
qu'elle fait vous voyez et je crois que
c'est réellement ça qu'il faut toucher
de fond et qu'il faut améliorer Merci à
VOUS Sonia de la prvotter pour
terminer merci monsieur le président de
ce temps de parole qui m'est accordé
monsieur le ministre euh je vais donc
poser quelques questions la première
concerne euh le le la mise en œuvre de
de de classes euh en petit effectif qui
ont donc ça s'est développé en Rep et en
Rep plus mais la question se posait de
développer aussi ce euh cette action
dans les secteurs dites quintil 1 dans
le en milieu rural c'est-à-dire où les
la situation sociale était
particulièrement défavorisée et est-ce
que ce déploiement a été envisagé je
sais que certains départements dont le
mien avait mis ça commencit à mettre ça
en œuvre est-ce que vous comptez
poursivre cette politique puisque ça
fait partie des axes que vous avez
développé celui des petits effectifs et
donc est-ce qu'il y a une stratégie qui
est mise en œuvre de ce point de vue ma
deuxième question porte sur
l'expérimentation en matière d'éducation
prioritaire certains de mes collègues
sont intervenus sur ce sujet on voit une
vous m'entendez oui on Mo une une
répartition c'était juste une précision
sur les territoires ruraux auquels vous
faisiez référence dans le cados quinttil
1 c'est enfin en tout cas moi monen
qualifier ces ces ces territoires de
quinttil 1 donc en fait c'est le quintil
qui correspond à la situation sociale la
plus difficile voilà donc c'est
l'équivalent de R pour r plus mais en
milieu rural voilà euh ça sera pas
décompté sur mon temps de parole
Président
si je vais donc parler donc de
l'expérimententation en matière
d'éducation prioritaire parce que vous
avez pas développé ce sujet lors de
notre précédente intervention enfin
précédente audition est-ce que vous
envisagez dans le cadre de ce budget de
quand même avancer sur sur cette
question de l'évolution de de
l'éducation prioritaire
puisque on avait déjà imaginer que ça ne
se fasse pas tout à fait à cout constant
cont tenu de l'élargissement de la
sectorisation et donc euh est-ce que
vous avez envisagé une évolution dans ce
domaine je vais vous parler de la
situation des directrices et directeur
d'école il devaitil avoir une évaluation
des temps de décharges qui sont
aussi qui concernent le le le budget
également et de l'accompagnement
administratif nécessaire complémentaire
qui pouvit être mise en œuvre pour les
grandes écoles et les directrices et les
directeurs d'éces qui ont en charge des
grandes écoles et d'un point qui devait
être fait en cdenen annuel qui avait été
demandé est-ce que il y a eu une
réflexion je sais bien que c'est le
premier budget que vous défendez mais il
est nécessaire de faire évoluer vite et
d'évaluer vite la mise en œuvre de la
loi concernant les directrices et
directeurs d'école et puis enfin sur les
classes à horair aménager où ces classes
qui en un temps encore un peu ancien
avait été qualifié
d'élitistees les classes bilang par
exemple toutes ces classes spécifique
est-ce que vous avez une stratégie par
rapport à au développement de de ces
classes et on sait que
notamment les classes spécifiques au
collège il a été décidé dans certaines
directions académiques de de de mettre
le temps spécifique dans la DAG
finalement de mettre à la main du chef
d'établissement l'avenir ou pas et le
destin de ces classes sportive ou à
voocation culturelle et à l'heure où on
parle du 100 % EAC et de l'accès à la
culture il me semble qu'elle mérite
d'être d'être soutenu dans le cadre de
votre ministère merci beaucoup
de nombreuses questions mais beaucoup se
recoupent oui donc vous allez pouvoir
faire une
synthèse merci monsieur le Président
effectivement je vais essayer de de
recouper tout ça mais quand même en
essayant de répondre à à
chacun je prends juste dans l'ordre
alors Monsieur Brisson m'a posé
plusieurs questions d'abord sur
l'ambition réformatrice au sein de ce
budget d'abord dans ce budget on y est
revenu au moment l'intervention
liminaire il y a notamment la traduction
budgétaire du pacte enseignant qui est
une réforme
elle nous permet de doubler quasiment
doubler nos capacités de remplacement de
courte durée par rapport à ce qui
existait dans le cadre du des heures
supplémentaires pour le RCD évidemment
tout n'est pas dans le budget s'agissant
des réformes structurelles j'aurai
l'occasion d'annoncer j'y reviendrai en
réponse à Madame goselin euh des
décisions au début du mois de décembre
sur l'élévation du niveau général dans
les matières fondament
et notamment le français et les et les
mathématiques donc j'y vois là aussi une
réforme structurelle qui ne se traduit
pas dans le dans le budget aujourd'hui
mais qui en tout cas va va intervenir je
reviendrai sur les pistes en vous
répondant madame la sénatrice sur la
formation c'est assez difficile pour moi
aujourd'hui de vous faire des annonces
et encore moins de les traduire dans le
PLF puisque je suis en pleine
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales par par respect pour la
discussion qu'on est en train d'avoir je
peux difficilement vous dire dire sur
quoi on va atterrir par ailleurs
évidemment c'est une discussion qui a
lieu aussi entre moi et ma collègue
Sylvie rotaillot puisque évidemment
quand on parle de formation des
enseignants de retour des écoles
normales ça peut potentiellement avoir
un impact aussi sur et çaa de toute
façon un impact sur le ministère
d'enseignement supérieur puisque quand
on dit qu'on repense la formation
initiale ça concerne aussi
l'enseignement supérieur on se voit
beaucoup avec ma collègue pour et
travailler et pour et pour en parler
donc il y a rien dans le PLF de ce point
de vue mais ça veut pas dire qu'il y a
pas la réforme au contraire on est en
train d'y travailler et de toute façon
quand vous changez les règles d'un
concours vous devez le faire plus d'un
an avant la date de ce concours donc de
toute façon ça ne pourrait pas avoir
lieu et se mettre en place en 2024 pour
le concours de 2024 donc je pense qu'on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler pour le
PLF 2025 même si je souhaite faire les
annonces et rendre les arbitrages sur la
réforme de la formation dès le début de
l'année 2024 justement pour qu'on puisse
anticiper la mise en place mais la la
les pistes de travail c'est d'avoir un
vrai un vrai continuum de formation du
baccalauréat au au Master c'est
d'anticiper le recrutement pour élargir
le vivier pour rendre et rendre le
concours plus sélectif et la formation
en master plus attractive voilà si je
devais donner les grands les grands
objectifs sur la question qui était
posée sur les contrat demions et les
secondes carrières oui on travaille sur
ce sujetl sur notamment la question de
la formation nos contractuels et j'aurai
l'occasion d'annoncer là aussi des
mesures sur les reconversions en en
seconde partie de carrière oui
évidemment je crois pas à la crise des
vocations je crois qu'il y a une crise
d'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
mais je crois pas une crise des
vocations on a tous autour de nous des
exemples de personnes qui à 30 40 ou 50
ans parfois après avoir une carrière
vraiment très éloignée de l'enseignement
ou du service public mais dans le privé
disent qu'ils ont envie de donner du
sens à leur vie à leur travail et qui
s'interrogent à l'idée de devenir
enseignant au contraire je pense qu'il y
a des opportunités d'aller euh chercher
des Françaises des Français qui ont
envie de servir leur pays l'intérêt
général et de le faire en en en
enseignant donc
euh on on on on a déjà pris un certain
nombre de mesures notamment encore un
décret cet été qui permet de reprendre
2/3 de l'ancienneté euh quand on euh
devient enseignant et qu'on passe le
concours après une carrière en dehors de
l'éducation nationale ça c'est quand
même un vrai progrès euh ensuite on euh
a ouvert un nouveau concours interne
spécial pour que des professeurs des
écoles contractuelles puissent être
titularisés c'est pour répondre à la
question qu'il évoquait l'an dernier ça
a permis plus de 300 titularisations sur
la projection pluriannuelle des
ouvertures fermetures de classe c'est un
engagement de la première ministre dans
le cadre de France ruralité il sera il a
évidemment tenu l'idée c'est d'avoir une
visibilité à 3 ans partagé avec les élus
dans le cadre d'instances local avec les
services de l'État je rappelle que selon
une étude de la DEP il y a en moyenne
deux élèves par classe de moins en rural
et un élève par classe de moins en en
élémentaire sur le CNR et le fond
d'innovation pédagogique oui c'est un
succès d'un point de vue quantitatif on
a déjà 10000 projets qui ont été enfin
portés et soumis aux commissions qui
évaluent ces projets je crois qu'on a un
peu moins de 4000 qui ont été validés ça
montre qu'il y a un succès quantitatif
je vous rejoins quand vous dites
monsieur Brisson qu'il faut aller
maintenant vers le qualitatif et donc ça
fait partie des consignes que j'ai donné
qu'on ait des projets qui soient
véritablement tournés vers l'innovation
pédagogique je dis pas que c'était pas
le cas auparavant en tout cas je pense
que c'est important qu'il y ait une
exigence très forte là-dessus ça passe
notamment par le fait je pense de mettre
en avant des projets on va dire
exemplaires pour donner un peu un modèle
de ce qu'on
considère comme devant émerger du fond
d'innovation pédagogique et de notre
école faisonsla ensemble ensuite la
vision de l'innovation moi ce que je
souhaite c'est une innovation au service
des savoirs je pense qu'à la fin c'est
quand même toujours ça qu'on recherche
c'est élévation du niveau des élèves
quand on
investit pour le développement d'outils
liés à l'intelligence artificielle on
fait pas pour faire joli ou parce que ça
fait moderne on le fait en se disant que
certains outils peuvent nous permettre
d'élever le niveau de nos élèves on
commence à le voir par exemple sur les
langues on a déployé un outil numérique
qui s'appelle Captain Kelly qu'on a
financé sur l'apprentissage de l'anglais
qui fonctionne très très bien et donc là
moi j'ai accep enfin j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai
validé le déploiement et c'est ça fait
notamment avec les fonds France 2030 de
budget supplémentair pour déployer
maintenant des outils sur
l'apprentissage de l'allemand euh et par
ailleurs sur le français pour élever le
niveau en français et donc on on on pour
moi pour moi l'innovation la la la
numérisation a du sens dès lors qu'elle
est au service de l'élévation du niveau
général ou de la diminution des
contraintes de nos enseignants et de nos
personnels je pense que c'est vraiment
les deux les deux leviers euh sur euh la
question de les questions de Madame
Monier
euh vous avez avis interrogé sur les
milieux de carrière c'est vrai il y a
beaucoup d'articles beaucoup d'études
sur ce que certains qualifient de blouse
de milieu de carrière d'abord il y a un
sujet sur sur la rémunération à l'issue
de toutes les mesures qui ont été prises
depuis la réélection du président de la
République on sera en janvier prochain
au-dessus de la moyenne OCDE pour la
rémunération des enseignants en début et
en fin de carrière et donc la difficulté
ça reste le milieu de carrière où il
reste effectivement un décrochage
important donc dans le cadre de la
concertation sur l'attractivité du
métier d'enseign que je mène
actuellement avec les organisations
syndicales j'ai mis sur la table la
question des milieux de carrière et
notamment de la progression du passage à
l'échelon supérieur pour redynamiser
aussi ce moment-là leur donner des
perspectives y compris en terme en terme
de rémunération mais j'insiste quand
même sur le fait que ces ces enseignants
ont eu des revalorisations et que si on
met les trois moments de revalorisation
depuis la réélection du président de la
République c'està-dire point d'indice
été 2022 point d'indice été 2023 et
valorisation socle en 7ette rentrée pour
un enseignant à 25 ans de carrière c'est
plus 234 € net par mois depuis avril
2022 alors certains me disent oui mais
vous mettez le point d'indice dedans euh
et c'est pas que pour les enseignants
enin moi j'ai toujours entendu les
organisations syndicales d'enseignants
demander une revalorisation du point
d'indice donc c'est bien que ça rentre
aussi dans la rémunération et j'ai envie
de dire tant mieux pour les autres
fonctionnaires s'ils y ont aussi droit
mais donc évidemment que que que tous
les enseignants ont bénéficié de cette
de ces revalorisation HH sur la question
de l'attractivité moi je veux insister
sur ce point on n'est pas les seuls à
vivre cette crise j'étais en Allemagne
avec le président de la République il y
a quelques semaines euh mes homologues
allemands me disaient qu' ils estimaient
que dans les 2 ans qui viennent ils
pourraent leur manquer 25000 enseignants
ils ont aussi un problème démographique
qu'on a moins heureusement même si on
regarde la natalité avec beaucoup euh
d'inquiétude
euh au Canada il manque 5000 postes
enfin 5000 enseignants euh et aux
États-Unis certains États ont décidé de
réduire ire la le volume des programmes
par manque d'enseignant donc je pense
qu'il y a une crise d'attractivité qui
est aussi beaucoup plus large beaucoup
plus globale que la seule que ce qu'on
constate en France qui concerne tous les
pays qui est aussi lié pour moi vous
avez parlé de la question de l'autorité
je vous rejoins totalement je riendrai
mais qui est aussi lié pour moi à la
question du la reconnaissance du rôle de
l'enseignant dans la
société à dans une époque où finalement
beaucoup viennent à considérer que tout
savoir se vaut que celui que vous
trouvez sur internet sur les réseaux
sociaux avec des pseudo experts et du
même niveau que celui qui est transmis
par l'enseignant ou celui qui sait bah
évidemment que ça remet en cause donc
moi je pense que c'est même pas enfin
c'est la question de l'autorité de
l'enseignant mais plus largement c'est
la question de l'autorité du savoir de
la science des faits établis y compris
historiquement quand on voit qu'il y a
même plus de d'unanimité politique
autour de la du soutien à à à et de la
reconnaissance de l'autorité du savoir
et de la science et des des faits
historiques ça a un impact sur la
société et derrière ça a un impact sur
la reconnaissance du métier d'enseignant
et de l'enseignant et la figure de
l'enseignant et ça pour y répondre c'est
pas le PLF qui va régler le problème
c'est c'est un sursaut collectif qui est
nécessaire en tout cas moi j'en suis
absolument convaincu sur l'école
inclusive on on recrute 3000 ETP en 2024
après 4000 ETP chaque année en 2021 2022
2023 et donc on a 140000 AES en cible à
fin 2024 c'est 15000 de plus qu'en 2022
on recrute des AES et on continuera à le
faire pour répondre aux besoins
d'accompagnement humain lorsqu'ils
existent mais je le dis il faut aussi
permettre à des élèves à besoins
particuliers qui ne sont pas
nécessairement en situation de handicap
ou reconnu comme tel par la MDPH c'est
évidemment toujours pour répondre à
certaines interventions la MDPH qui
notifiera
euh qui donnera le statut d'élève en
situation de handicap à un élève et pas
l'éducation nationale l'éducation
nationale ce qu'on propose avec les
passes c'est de pouvoir apporter une
adaptation du matériel pédagogique ou
des enseignements à des élèves qui ont
des besoins particuliers on sait qu'il
peuvent être plus larges que le handicap
et donc je pense que cette possibilité
de de donner euh plus euh d'autonomie ça
sera utile au service des élèves
aujourd'hui en moyenne la mise à
disposition d'un matériel pédagogique
adapté c'est 9 mois faut 9 mois moi tout
ce qui permet d'anticiper ça encore une
fois sans revenir sur le rôle de la MDPH
mais juste pour que des élèves qui en
ont besoin puissent avoir plus
rapidement un matériel pédagogique
adapté je pense que il faut il faut
évidemment le faire et l'objectif qu'on
a avec les passes c'est que ça soit 3
mois maximum ENF de de délai pour pour
pour ce matériel pédagogique adapté sur
le salaire moyen des
aesh
euh
c'était ce sera 994 € c'est ça en en
janvier 2024 moyen pour une quotité de
travail à 62 % qui est la quotité
moyenne voilà euh sur la concertation
autour des passes je veux quand même le
dire il y a eu évidemment une
concertation c pas moi qui étaé ministre
de l'éducation nationale à l'époque mais
dans le cadre du
comité de la Conférence nationale du
handicap il y a eu quand même des
travaux qui ont été mené il y a un
comité national de suivi de l'école
inclusive qui est co-présidé par Fadil
katabi et moi-même il se réunira le 11
décembre les décrets d'application
seront soumis au CNCPH évidemment et il
y a des groupes de travail partenaire à
un rythme trimestriel sur tous les
dossiers de la Conférence nationale du
handicap et toutes les mesures de la CNH
par ailleurs mon équipe échange très
régulièrement avec des membres du du
CNCPH ils étaient encore reçus cet
après-midi à mon cabinet et et je le dis
hein certains membres duncph salue y
compris publiquement hein je me tourne
vers ma conseillère chargée de l'école
inclusive mais euh la transformation des
piales en passe euh donc je pense qu'il
faut aussi les entendre moi j'entends
parfaitement qu'il a les inquiétudes
encore une fois et c'est des situations
tellement difficiles pour des familles
qui aujourd'hui ont pas de solution qui
ont réussi en avoir une après des mois
avoir des années d'attente que j'entends
que quand on parle de changement bah ça
ça crée des inquiétudes mais vraiment
j'y crois donc voilà je je j'entends pas
qu'on puisse ne pas y croire mais je
pense que on peut arriver à convaincre
et et encore une fois on est prêt même à
monter une réunion dédiée si vous le
souhaitez avec mon équipe
et les spécialistes sur ce sur ce sujet
là enfin ben je crois que Madame Monier
je vous ai répondu je
j'accélère éducation à la sexualité
effectivement je n'en ai pas parlé
oui c'est vrai
que la le
le les temps prévus dans la loi ne sont
pas respectés partout ça c'est sûr et
même pas dans la majorité des cas mais
avant de dire il faut faire respecter la
loi que ça soit respecté partout moi je
veux et je l'assume sincèrement attendre
qu'on clarifie ce qu'on met dans cet
enseignement et donc c'est pour ça que
le Conseil supérieur des programmes a
été
missionné le Conseil supérieur des
programmes il est compétent pour faire
des programmes on l'a missionné sur
cette question là il doit me remettre
une proposition au mois de décembre et à
partir de là on
avancera moi je vais vous dire ce que je
souhaite ce que
j'attends c'est d'abord de la
transparence il faut que les familles
puissent savoir exactement ce qu'on fait
dans le cadre de ces
enseignements parce que aussi ça peut
parfois alimenter des
instrumentalisations des
fantasmes il faut toujours avoir en tête
et évidemment être extrêmement clair sur
le fait que il y a un âge pour tout et
il y a un âge pour parler de tout mais
on parle pas de ces sujets de la même
manière en CP et en terminal évidemment
oui mais mais ça va mieux en le 10ans et
en
rappelant et je vais vous dire moiême
parler d'éducation parler éducation
sexuelle en
CP j'ai un j'ai je je je je suis pas sûr
voilà je pense que il y a l'école
primaire il y a l'école primaire on doit
vous apprendre l'intégrité du
corps le consentement et par ailleurs
j'ajouterai puisque je développe ça la
question de l'empathie de la
bienveillance de la tolérance du respect
de l'autre et ensuite je pense qu'on
doit s'attaquer
euh de manière effectivement et rendre
plus effectif euh les questions de bah
de de de
de d'éducation à la vie affective
relationnelle et sexuelle comme on
l'appelle la réalité et on voit bien
aujourd'hui dans les baromètres qui sont
fait l'urgence qui a d'avancer sur cette
question là c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez un garçon sur TR qui déclare dans
les enquêtes considérer qu'une femme
peut aimer être forcée dans une relation
sexuelle et que vous avez plus de 40 %
des garçons qui décareent s'informer
sur la manière d'avoir des relations
sexuelles en regardant du porno sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur
Internet une fois qu'on a dit ça en
matière d'impact sur les violences
sexuelles les violences en direction des
femmes on voit qu'il y a un enjeu quand
même que ça pose plein de question sur
le numérique sur l'accès aux réseaux
sociaux pour chez beaucoup de jeunes qui
qui qui est terrible donc quand on parle
de ces questions là c'est un problème
qui est concerne toute la société qui
concerne pas que l'école c'est pas
l'école de régler tout ce problème là
toute seule mais en tout cas elle peut y
prendre sa part je suis d'accord avec
vous sur ce sujet là mais et moi je
redis je ne souhaite pas
d'instrumentalisation politique d'un
côté ou de l'autre de cette question je
vous dis parce que ça fait du je dis pas
ça pour vous hein mais parfois j'entends
certaines voix je me pose la question et
je pense que ça fait du mal à la cause
que certains prétendent défendre donc
faire un sujet
politique madame billon sur le pacte
mais en fait d'abord il a jamais été
question que tous les enseignants
signent le pacte pour ça faut être très
clair sur le sujet ne serit-ce que pour
des raisons pour le coûp budgétaire ça
n'est pas possible ça pas été euh c'est
pas prévu euh il y en a pas pour tout le
monde euh donc c'est par
ailleurs sans que tous les enseignants
rejoignent le PACT peut assez largement
couvrir les besoins euh qu'on souhaite
couvrir à travers le PACT mon
prédécesseur avait parlé d'une cible à
30 % moi je me suis toujours gardé de de
fixer une cible on est on y est presque
pe en dessous mais surtout entre-
tempemps il y a eu un changement parce
que quand je suis arrivé au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
j'ai pas évidemment remis toute la
question du pacte sur la table pour tout
refondre parce que il y avait eu
beaucoup de de travail qui avait été
fait et en plus les textes sont sortis
assez tard en juillet on pouvait pas
tous les reprendre mais en tout cas j'ai
pris une décision consistant à dire que
la première mission qui doit être
distribuée dans le cadre du du pacte et
vraiment je l'ai dit de manière très
prescriptive au chef d'établissement ça
doit être le remplacement de courte
durée ce qui qui était pas le c'était
pas la même règle avant que
j'arrive et donc
euh moi j'aiété très clair je leaurais
même dit je préfère un peu moins de Pact
avec beaucoup plus de remplacement de
courte durée que beaucoup de pactes avec
d'autres missions que le remplacement de
courte durée donc j'assume qu'on soit un
Chouat en dessous de l'objectif qui
avait été fixé par mon prédécesseur
puisque j'ai un peu durci les règles en
arrivant sur le sujet mais ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'on est très nettement au-dessus
de ce que beaucoup nous promettaient
encore au début d'année à la rentrée
nous expliquant qu'il y avait 10 % des
enseignants non on est beaucoup dessus
et ça continue à il continue à y avoir
des enseignants qui s'engagent après on
fera un bilan moi je suis très
pragmatique on fera un bilan dans le
courant de l'année sur les personnels de
direction on est on a entamé un travail
de de discussion avec eux sur la
question de la rémunération donc je peux
pas vous en dire plus aujourd'hui mais
en tout cas je peux vous dire qu'en
terme de calendrier je souhaite aboutir
en janvier 2024 donc ça ça va aller
assez vite sur les passes je crois que
j'ai répondu sur éducation à la vie vie
effective relationnelle et sexuelle
aussi madame darkos sur euh je n'arrive
plus à me
relire le Pass Culture ah oui non sur
euh sur le numérique
euh oui oui oui on a 9 millions d'euros
qui sont alloués au numérique éducatif
pour financer les ressources numériques
à l'école dans le PLF
2024 somme à laquelle s'ajoute les
financements extérieurs qui viennent de
France 2030 dans dans le cadre de la
stratégie enseignement et numérique euh
et notamment dans les territoires
éducatifs euh les tne les territoires
numériques éducatif même si euh c'est
vrai
que il peut y avoir il faut qu'on
regarde vraiment collectivité par
collectivité il faut que mes services le
fassent finement des endroits où c'est
vraiment impossible et donc mais sinon
quand même moi je préfère que les
crédits qu'on a sur la question du
numérique soit vraiment tourner vers euh
l'innovation pédagogique et c'est-à-dire
les outils qu'on met à disposition des
enseignants pour les élèves et moins
vers de l'équipement qui est pas la
compétence de l'État en tout cas vous
voyez qu'il y a encore des budgets
évidemment l'objectif c'est que les
élèves puissent puissent les avoir sur
euh pardon le Pass Culture
eu l'objectif c'est comment ouais
l'objectif c'est que ça soit simple pour
eux et et et on a déployé la la
plateforme
adage qui permet de sélectionner les
activités ou les sorties scolaires qu'il
souhaitent organiser et de le faire de
manière assez simple euh euh donc après
sur la formation des enseignants je
pense que il y a à la fois la
connaissance par les établissements il y
a encore des collèges qui sont pas au
courant que il y a cet accès sur la
formation des enseignants évidemment
c'est aussi un enjeu important qu'on va
qu'on va poursuivre enfin sur la
question du périscolaire pour le coup
euh on est un peu comment dire
euh on doit suivre une décision du
Conseil d'État qui est sans ambigué sur
le fait que euh le partage des
compétences entre l'éducation nationale
sur le temps scolaire et les
collectivités locales sur le
périiscolaire est très est très CLA donc
j'ai demandé à mes services là il
viennent de relancer une enquête pour
dresser un état des lieux sur euh les
conventions qui ont été conclues en
entre l'éducation nationale et les
collectivités territoriales pour le
l'intervention des aesh sur le sur le
temps spériscolaire je sais qu'il y en a
un certain nombre qui ont été conclus à
titre gracieux donc voilà ce qui ce qui
est pas tout à fait qui ne respecte pas
tout à fait jurisprudence du Conseil
d'État donc faut voir comment est-ce
qu'on est capable d'avancer mais encore
une fois l'objectif effectivement c'est
que un on fasse progresser on améliore
la rémunération des aesh en leur
permettant d'avoir plus d'heur souvent
elle le demande et deux qu'on sorte de
situations un peu ubesque où vous
avez le midi des aesh qui ne sont pas en
temps de travail qui sont pas rémunérés
à ce titre là et des élèves en situation
de handicap qui sont à la cantine et qui
ont pas le meilleur accompagnement qu'on
pourrait souhaiter pour eux à la cantine
donc euh faut qu'on continue à avancer
là-dessus mais là la jurisprudence du
Conseil d'État ne nous permet pas de
faire ce qu'on veut euh madame euh
ensuite c'était monsieur laelec euh
alors je leur dit he personne n' parlé
de ouais mais bon comme j'ai répondu à
Monsieur Brisson qui est parti je vais
répondre à Monsieur L qui est parti
aussi
euh mais c'est vraiment c'est c'est un
je ferai pas ça à chaque fois parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours suivi cette
règles euh mais euh personne n'a parlé
de fin du collège unique c'est important
de le rappeler euh évidemment euh moi
simplement ce que j'ai dit c'est que
dans le cadre de la mission exigence des
savoirs que j'ai confié je souhaite
qu'on pose la question de groupe de
niveau sur le français et les
mathématiques au collège et ça rejoint
ce que je je développerai tout à l'heure
sur le niveau en français et en math moi
ce que me disent beaucoup d'enseignants
c'est on a des classes avec un niveau
tellement hétérogène qu'on a du mal à
faire progresser qui que ce soit en fait
et en fait à la fin tout le monde finit
par stagner régresser parce qu'on
aimerait passer du temps avec des élèves
qui sont très largué en retard mais du
coup ceux qui ne le sont pas ne
progressent pas et quand on veut les
faire progresser eux bah on a les autres
qui sont largués donc moi je suis pas
pour revenir aux classes de niveau
global pour qui concerne l'intégralité
de la classe mais au moins sur le
français les maths pour pouvoir avoir
des groupes de niveau moi en tout cas ça
je je à titre personnel je pense que
c'est une piste intéressante maintenant
un j'ai confié une mission qui doit me
remettre ses travaux à la fin du mois de
novembre de j'ai lancé une consultation
des enseignants à laquelle beaucoup
d'enseignants répondent d'ailleurs je
sais pas combien on est de réponses plus
100000 ouais on était à plus de 100000
alors queon l'a ouverte euh au début des
vacances euh donc juste sur les vacances
on a 100000 enseignants qui ont répondu
donc euh voilà euh sur
euh sur la la la formation continue oui
je le redis euh euh on est en dessous de
la moyenne de l'OCDE sur le nombre de
jours en formation continue on n par
ailleurs moins d'un enseignant sur deux
au collège qui a recours à la formation
continue et à peine plus d'un enseignant
sur 3 au lycée moi quand on m'explique
que la formation continue
aujourd'hui est est parfaite entre
guillemets non donc c'est pour ça que
moi j'assume totalement de dire qu'on
met la formation continue en dehors du
temps de classe ce qui nous permettra de
rattraper 2 millions d'heures qui
étaient perdu jusqu'à maintenant pour
les élèves mais surtout je pense que il
faut faire de ce choix-là une
opportunité pour repenser l'organisation
de la formation continue pour qu'elle
réponde davantage aux besoins et aux
attentes des enseignants en maintenir de
contenu et en matière d'organisation
avec des modules plus c'est cables
hybrides sur site et c'est ce qu'on est
en train de travailler euh monsieur Zian
euh parti aussi mais je lui réponds
également
euh monsieur Zian je me l'tais
noté oui alors euh sur la répartition
des euh aesh c'est pour ça qu'on
continue j'entends les difficultés et
les familles qui attendent c'est pour ça
qu'on continue à recruter c'est pour ça
qu'on cdise aussi pour fidéliser les
AESA je vous ai donné les chiffres tout
à l'heure c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
qu'on qu'on crée les les passes pour
avoir des réponses plus rapides mais il
faut mesurer quand même qu'on a créé un
nouveau service public hein avec l'école
inclusive quand on regarde le volume
budgétaire le nombre d'Es le nombre
d'élèves qui sont accueillis 50 % de
plus qu'en 2017 on a quand même c'est un
nouveau budget dans le budget quand même
quasiment un nouveau ministère dans le
ministère les av c'est la deuxième
profession du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale maintenant maintenant il faut
il faut aller vers le le le qualitatif
on a eu l'occasion
de euh d'y revenir madame de donc sur
formation continue j'ai répondu sur
leemi oui moi je souhaite qu'on puisse
avoir un temps dédié et je pense que
euh à côté des savoirs fondamentaux lire
écrire compter on voit depuis plusieurs
années qu'on souhaite que maintenant il
est respecté autrui dedans que
malheureusement il faut le l'affirmer
comme tel et j'ajouterai décrypter
l'information parce que je pense que
c'est devenu fondamental que de savoir
décrypter une information à laquelle on
est confronté sur les réseaux sociaux
sur sur Internet et que là il y a encore
beaucoup d'inégalités entre les les
territoires et les établissements on a
en plus on sait objectivement quels sont
les outils on a le Clémi qui a beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus on a par ailleurs
enfin beaucoup d'aeurs qui se sont
engagés on a des enseignants
remarquables qui qui s'engagent aussi
sur ces questions maintenant il faut
arriver à à ce qu'on ait la garantie que
tous les élèves ont des temps
d'éducation au médias et à l'information
donc ça rentre dans la réflexion qui est
en cours sur la réforme de l'EMC
l'enseignement moral et civique là aussi
j'attends les propositions du Conseil
supérieur des programmes mais je vous
confirme que leemi euh fera partie des
grandes orientations d'une du nouvelle
EMC désolé pour les acronymes qu'on va
déployer euh même si je le redis he
parce que j'ai entendu beaucoup sur les
jeunes s'informment sur les réseaux
sociaux et les fake news et cetera je je
je je fais pas de du tout de génération
contre génération je pense que c'est un
enjeu global et je veux dire qu'il y a
des enquêtes aussi très sérieuses qui
montrent que compris chez les seniors
les fake news se répandent beaucoup via
les réseaux sociaux aussi euh donc je
pense que c'est important quand même que
il y a aussi une prise de conscience
collective qui concerne toute la société
euh j'en étais ensuite à Monsieur fialer
euh sur le SNU évidemment il faut
continuer à se mobiliser
l'administration pour qu'elle fasse
connaître le SNU vous avez raison mais
je suis quand même c'est moi qui ai
lancé le SNU en 2019 donc je suis
convaincu par le dispositif et donc je
vais évidemment mobiliser mon
administration sur sur le sujet
euh où sont les 183 élèves qui ont été
exclus à titre conservatoire après avoir
perturbé gravement les tempants dommag
je rappelle que c'est quand même 183 sur
un peu plus de 500 perturbations euh les
183 c'est ceux qui ont fait de
l'apologie du terrorisme ou des menaces
directes en direction d'un enseignant
donc là c'est vraiment donc ils sont
chez eux en attendant leur conseil de
discipline et c'est le conseil de
discipline qui statura sur leur
situation euh je je mets je je je
rappelle que c'est pas le même sujet que
la question des élèves radicalisés
dangereux peut-être que dans ces élèves
il y a des élèves qui sont vraiment
radicalisés on est en train de
évidemment de regarder toutes les
situations mais je pense qu'il faut pas
mélanger les deux sujets euh vous savez
le terroriste d'aras euh et son frère
quand il avait eu l'assassinat de Samuel
paatti et le temps dommage à l'époque
ils avaient pas perturbé le temps
domommage ils étaient même pas ils
étaient pas venus ce jour-là j'étais
regardé dans le dossier scolaire ils
avaient été absents donc tout ça pour
dire que il faut pas faire enfin tirer
des des des des conclusions automatiques
voilà il y a eu des perturbations et
certaines perturbations graves du temps
dommage elles sont inacceptables ne
serait-ce que parce qu'on doit faire
respecter des règles et rappeler que il
y a des moments qui sont symboliquement
très important pour la mémoire
d'enseignants qui sont morts et qui sont
importants symboliquement pour le
respect de l'autorité et des règles à
l'école et que ça nécessite des
sanctions et donc ils sont exclus à
titre conservatoire dans l'attente de
leur conseil de discipline qui staturera
sur
euh les détachements alors moi ce que ce
que ce que j'ai comme chiffre c'est
qu'on a 1,4 % d'enseignants en
détachement donc ça fait 12000 12000
personnes c'est répertorié au panorama
statistique des personnels de
l'enseignement scolaire et donc dans ce
panorama statistique il y a toutes les
informations et toutes les données qui
sont précisées si vous avez des
questions plus précises sur certaines
données qui ne figuraient pas dans le
panorama vous pouvez tout à fait les les
adresser à à mon équipe et puis on
répondra les adressés
euh monsieur Ross
oui vous êtes présent tout à fait donc
vous aurez une
réponse sur le le le
harcèlement évidemment que l'exclusion
n'est pas enfin on peut pas se ne peut
pas suffire c'est pour ça qu'on est en
train de revoir le protocole avec les
chefs d'établissement parce que que je
pense que dans certains cas il faut un
accompagnement psychologique je parle
bien des harceleurs parce que souvent
vous en avez qui sont harceleurs il sont
pas très bien dans leur dans leur tête
et donc c'est bien qu'il a aussi un
accompagnement psychologique et et moi
je souhaite par ailleurs qu'on ait c'est
c'est le travail qu'on en train d'avoir
une un peu une nouvelle organisation des
sanctions on a parfois tendance trop à
attendre que la situation pourrisse pour
convoquer un conseil de discipline et
prendre des sanctions graves or je pense
que une sanction même si elle est plus
légère du moment qu'elle arrive très
vite dès les premières les premiers
signes du harcèlement c'est peut-être
plus efficace finalement euh et ça
permettrait d'éviter des drames humains
et des situations qui pourrissent donc
on est en train de faire ce travail on
peut tout à fait prendre des sanctions
dans un établissement sans conseil de
discipline il y a des commissions
éducatives qui sont possibles et donc
c'est ça qu'on est en train de
travailler et je souhaite qu'on qu'on
puisse avancer sur sur ce sujet de plus
efficace sur les rythmes scolaire je
vous avez pas répondu tout simplement
parce que pour moi la position c'est euh
celle qui a été exprimée en 2017 par le
président de la République et qui
s'applique depuis la liberté qui a été
laissée sur les évaluations je pense
qu'il y a toujours effectivement des
rapports qui sont faits et laad doit
produire régulièrement il y en a pas eu
récemment me dit-on si on peut en avoir
je pense c'est toujours utile non mais
c'est toujours utile il y a aussi des
rapports de recherche qui sont faits
mais je ne souhaite pas en tout cas pour
être très clair je ne souhaite pas
remettre ce débat sur la table voilà euh
pas en tout cas moi en tant que moi en
tant que ministre
euh sur le lien avec la recherche pour
la formation des enseignants oui c'est
très important et donc quel que soit les
décisions qu'on prendra sur la formation
initiale je pense que c'est important
qu'il puisse y avoir un lien avec la
recherche parce qu'elle est essentielle
pour nos enseignants en
formation monsieur ingret sur la loi sur
le
cyberhcèlement la loi de 2022 elle a été
très importante parce qu'elle a permis
de faire rentrer le harcèlement scolaire
dans notre code pénal faut bien se
rendre compte qu'avant l'élection du
Président de la République en 2017 le
harcèlement scolaire était absent de
tous nos codes
ni le code de l'éducation ni le code
pénal c'est en 2019 qu'on a fait rentrer
le harcèlement scolaire dans le code de
l'éducation et en 2022 dans le code
pénal donc c'est assez tôt finalement
pour mesurer l'application il y a une
décision de justice qui a beaucoup ému
euh les Français et vous l'avez rappelé
c'est votre département on a pas le
droit de commenter enfin en tant que
responsable politique et la séparation
des pouvoirs on commande pas les
décision mais moi en tout cas je voilà
j'ai beaucoup pensé à la famille et j'ai
vu que beaucoup de Français étaient émus
je pense que ça sera important de voir
comment cette loi s'applique et le cas
échéant si si ça s'avérait nécessaire de
la faire évoluer mais je suis pas non
plus pour dire qu'il faut qu'elle évolue
tout de suite je pense que c'est
important qu'elle s'applique sur le
cyberhcèlement c'est la loi sur l'espace
numérique qui est en train d'être
discutée par le Parlement qui va être
très importante avec le bannissement des
réseaux sociaux
euh avec un certain nombre de mesures
qui sont prises sur la
responsabilisation des cyberhceleurs
avec les boutons de signalement qui vont
enfin arriver sur les réseaux sociaux
pour le 3018 je pense que là on aura
quand même un certain nombre de
progrès
sur les parents et le temps scolaire
pour partir en
vacances sujet récurrent qui revient
souvent moi je vais vous dire plus
globalement je trouve que il faut un
moment qu'il ait un un moment peut-être
un peu symbolique mais je pense que les
symboles ont une part importante mais en
tout cas qu'on rappelle un moment quels
sont les droits et les obligations de
chacun y compris des parents vis-à-vis
de l'établissement de l'établissement
vis-à-vis des parents aujourd'hui quand
vous êtes parents vous signez au mieux
fait toujours c'est fait souvent mais
vous signez le règlement intérieur de
l'établissement au début de l'année
scolaire mais le règlement intérieur de
l'établissement il concerne la vie
interne de l'établissement votre enfant
avec l'établissement moi je considère
que les familles devraient signer un
contrat en fait avec leur établissement
l'établissements scolaires de leur
enfant qui rappellent les droits et les
obligations de
chacun ça me semblerait voilà être
important et ensuite qu'en cas de
manquement ce contrat prévoit en cas de
manquement grave à ses obligations
notamment celle de l'assiduité de son
enfant celle de la participation des
parents aller chercher les bulletins
scolaires soi-même euh la participation
euh à l'éducation de l'enfant il puisse
y avoir des sanctions voilà moi je pense
que ça serait une piste intéressante des
par par ou oui oui oui bien sûr avec des
stages de responsabilisation peut-être
avec des sanctions pécuniaires euh voilà
si les règles sont rappelées qu'elles
sont partagées et que sur la base de ces
règles partagé inscrites dans une forme
de contrat avec les droits et
obligations de chacun on constate qu'il
y a un manquement grave bah moi oui je
considère que il faut que ça puisse être
rorti de
sanction Monsieur Madame goselin donc je
confirme votre chiffre que vous aviez
qui de vos établissements ce qui montre
que nos évaluations nationales
correspondent à la réalité du terrain un
élève sur 3 qui rentre en 6e ne maîtrise
pas convenablement la lecture l'écriture
et le calcul et je le dis on sait
d'avance que la plupart de ces élèves
vont décrocher comment vous voulez
réussir en histoire goéo si vous ne
savez pas lire réussir en physique si
vous ne savez pas compter c'est c'est
c'est c'est dramatique et donc c'est là
où vous avez raison on doit continuer
investir massivement sur le premier
degré ce qui est quand même le sens de
tout ce qu'on a fait depuis 2017
ouais et et et je veux dire quand vous
prenez le budget par élève dans le
premier degré en 2017 et le budget par
élève dans le premier degré aujourd'hui
c'est 1000 € de plus par élève enfin
c'est massif on a créé 11000 postes dans
le premier degré pour pouvoir réduire la
taille des classes et cetera on va
continu à
investir je le redis je le redis
certains ont parl des 2500 suppression
de poste si on voulez rester à taux
d'encadrement constant avec le même
nombre d'élèves par classe il faudra
supprimer 5000 postes donc on crée 2500
postes de plus que ce qui est nécessaire
pour garder le même taux d'encadrement
qu'aujourd'hui donc on va continuer à
améliorer le taux d'encadrement l'an
prochain parce que la démographie la
démographie diminue on va continuer à
améliorer le taux d'encadr rement mais
il y a évidemment tout le travail qu'on
mène dans le cadre de la mission
exigence des savoirs on est le pays de
l'OCDE qui doit consacrer le plus de
temps au français et au math dans le
premier degré dans l'emploi du temps des
élèves et pourtant on voit bien que les
résultats sont pas totalement
rendez-vous donc c'est bien que ça n'est
pas le temps consacré mais c'est c'est
ce qui se passe pendant ce temps il y a
un enjeu sur les manuels scolaires
beaucoup d'élèves nont pas de manuel de
référence et parfois le manuel qui est
utilisé n'utilise pas les méthodes
prouvées par la science comme étant les
bonnes pour apprendre à lire et à écrire
donc là se pose la question d'une forme
de labellisation des manuels je sais que
c'est un sujet sensible qui fait débat
depuis des années mais en tout cas je
pense qu'il faut la poser
euh comment
oui ensuite il y a la question des
cycles elle se pose aussi est-ce que
c'est efficace ou pas pour le niveau des
élèves il y a Desbat en tout cas on va
m'éclairer puisque c'est fait partie de
la mission que j'ai donné il y a la
question du du redoublement à des âches
clés encore une fois quand on reprend
tout à l'heure la données sur la
statistique sur la 6e laisser passer un
élève en 6e sans savoir lire écrire
compter dans les mêmes conditions que
les autres je suis pas sûr que ça soit
lui rendre service donc un moment est-ce
qu'on arrive à un système où on dit soit
vous refaites une année de CM2 qui sera
pas la même année que la précédente mais
en tout cas adapté soit vous passez en
6e et vous faites votre rentrée de
semaines avant les autres et vous avez
des stages de réussite pendant les
petites
vacances voilà mais en tout cas vous
voyez bien que il y a plein d'idées sur
le collège j'ai déjà dit les groupes de
niveau en français et en et en
math on va on va avancer on va avancer
également sur le mal-être de beaucoup
d'enseignants je je
je enfin évidemment moi j'échange
beaucoup avec eux le représentant
évidemment les syndicats mais aussi en
me déplaçant sur le terrain ça rejoint
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur la la
place de l'enseignant la reconnaissance
de l'enseignant et l'autorité de son
savoir ça passe aussi par je pense une
forme de remise en cause par des
familles qui avaient moins
avant forme de de de d'esprit de
comportement de consommateur presque
demander en permanence des comptes à
remettre en cause l'évaluation et cetera
et et ce sentiment parfois qu'on est
passé du droit à l'éducation au droit
sur l'éducation
euh donc je pense que ça doit aussi nous
alerter c'est des enjeux sociétaux qui
je pense pas qu'une décision politique
comme ça per per met d'y répondre en
moin une décision budgétaire mais en
tout cas je pense qu'en tant que
responsable politique on a aussi une
responsabilité pour pour avancer sur
cette question euh madame de La
provoté sur quintil 1 donc on va
regarder mais en tout cas pour vous dire
tout ce qui est territoir éducatifs
ruraux tout ce qui est dispositif de
soutien renforcé pour les euh les
territoires ruraux qui ont un IPS faible
et dans lesquels il y a des élèves issus
de familles modeste ou pauvre évidemment
l'objectif c'est de c'est de en fait
j'is pris c'est pour ça j'ai j'ai j'ai
je vous ai pas oublié les autres mais
j'ai pris la feuille à l'envers donc
j'ai c'était la fin madame de La pruté
mais euh mais donc on va continuer à
investir dessus d'ailleurs on va
développer massivement les TER l'année
prochaine je crois qu'on double
quasiment le nombre de territoires
éducatifs ruraux sur la carte de
l'éducation prioritaire le calendrier ça
va être
de travailler la nouvelle carte en
2024 pour 2025 faut qu'elle s'applique
en 2025 c'est pour ça qu'il il y a pas
de d'impact budgétaire là mais en tout
cas ça va être ça le l'objectif sur le
temps de décharge ça a beaucoup
progressé après la loi rilac et sur les
classes sport culturell biling moi je
suis très favorable je pense que par
ailleurs il faut les déployer en
priorité dans précisément les
établissements que vous évoquez c'estàd
ceux qui sont dans les quartiers les
plus difficiles que ce soit dans la
ruralité ou euh dans les quartiers
politiques de la ville je pense que
c'est aussi un enjeu d'attractivité de
l'école publique dans ces quartiers euh
par exemple en cette rentrée on ouvre 15
nouvelles sections internationales elles
sont toutes dans ces établissements là
euh je pense que donc moi je les
soutiens beaucoup je j'ai jamais compris
ces critiques sur le côté c'est
élitistes et cetera si vous les mettez
dans des établissements qui sont plus
euh mixte socialement il y a une
population qui est qui est plus modeste
euh bah enfin on est content de faire
des élites dans ces établissements là
c'est quand même le rôle de l'école
républicaine euh madame euh Ventalon sur
l'application
des 30 minutes d'activité physique
quotidienne dans nos établissements
alors les chiffres qui avaient été
donnés par ma collègue à ma connaissance
sont les bons c'est-à-dire qu'on aurait
autour de 15 % des écoles qui n'auraient
pas encore mis en place les 30 minutes
d'activité physiqu quotidienne mais pour
tout vous dire j'ai relancé une enquête
sur le sujet pour que on est on a des
chiffres actualisés qui qui remontent
ensuite il y a les 30 minutes et les 30
minutes minutes c'està-dire que parfois
les 30 minutes sont vraiment faites d'un
blog dans la cour et cetera parfois
c'est divisé en plusieurs temps dans la
journée je pense par ailleurs que les
enseignants font comme ils
peuvent il y a un kit qui leur a été
adressé il y a des éléments nouveaux qui
vont leur être
adressés notamment pour par la
Fédération française de rugby on
travaille avec eux mais en en tout cas
je mesure qu'on a besoin là d'y voir un
peu plus clair sur la manière dont ça se
déploie le nombre d'établissement qu'ils
font nom d'École qu'il font et comment
c'est fait donc ça on on relance une
enquête sur le sujet pour avoir des
données oui dire quel chose non pardon
on a prévu aussi de faire une mission
flash pour essayer de d'appréhender un
peu mieux ce sujet parce que vous dites
15 % des établissements c'est pas
forcément 15 % des classes non plus donc
oui c'est ça en tout cas ça nous aidera
si vous essez une mission flash
parlementaire sur le sujet on sera ravi
parce que on en a besoin madame Brossel
vous m'avez interroger sur la santé
scolaire qui n'augmenterait pas qui
n'augmente pas dans ce budget donc
effectivement il y a un amendement qui
avait été adopté socialiste et
Renaissance qui n'a pas été retenu par
le gouvernement dans le 493 bon après on
sait que sur la santé scolaire euh il y
a beaucoup de postes qui sont ouverts
qui ne sont pas pourvus euh donc il y a
aussi un enjeu de démographie médicale
on manque de professionnels de santé
dans beaucoup d'endroit et ceux qu'on
trouve pas à l'école en général c'est
ceux qu'on trouve pas non plus dans en
libéral ou dans des hôpitaux autour donc
ça c'est surtout très vrai pour les
médecins scolaires il faut se rendre
compte qu'on a 45 % de post vacant de
médecins scolaires 45 %. euh sur les
infirmières c'est objectivement un peu
moins le cas on en manque un peu moins
et donc moi je pense qu'on peut regarder
beaucoup de choses pour renforcer
l'attractivité de ces postes c'est pas
forcément toujours de la rémunération
parce que on a beaucoup augmenté ces
dernières années depuis 2020 la
rémunération des infirmières scolaires
je crois que c'est quoi autour de 15 %
14 % d'augmentation de rémunération
depuis 2020 depuis cette année elles ont
la prime REP plus aussi qu' l'urait
ouverte donc il y a eu ses progrès je
pense qu'on peut imaginer des exercices
mixtes permettre à une infirmière
scolaire si elle le souhaite mais ça m'a
été proposé par le terrain ça dans un
établissement qui est dans un
établissement de cumulé avec du libéral
à côté je pense ça peut être un levier
d'attractivité donc ça c'est des choses
qu'on est en train de regarder sur les
aides sociales non encore une fois il y
a pas d'économie faite sur les aides
sociales c'est c'est c'est c'est du fait
de la baisse démographique et c'est de
la constatation ce que je veux dire
c'est que on pourrait ouvrir et mettre
plus de crédit sur les fonds sociaux
dans le PLF de toute façon ça ne serait
pas consommé puisque c'est c'est selon
la démographie c'est bien tu confirmes
je voilà euh donc et au contraire on
rend même les bourses l'attribution des
bourses automatiques donc ça va même on
va même dépenser plus infin parce que
des gens qui n'y ont pas accès enfin qui
ne les demandent pas il auront accès euh
sur le Pass Culture collectif
euh on en a
parlé sur euh Madame B RTI attractivité
n'est pas que pécunière il y a
l'autorité oui ça je l'ai dit aussi
stage de seconde en ruralité
je parlé de la mobilisation des
collectivités territoriales et je crois
que j'ai fait le
tour peut-être Cédric Vial sur les les
service civique vous avez répondu sur le
passou sur le service CIV sur le service
civique on a on a question de Monsieur
Vial on a 520 million d'euros en PLF
2024 et 150000 jeunes volontaires le but
c'est de faire aussi 150000 jeunes en
2023 on continue donc à à mobiliser
jusqu'à la fin de l'année on est à
135000 aujourd'hui donc l'objectif est
atignable
en
2022 il y avait effectivement un reste
de trésorerie et le PLF de fin de
gestion je m'en souviens puisque c'était
moi qui était au budget avait réduit de
83 million d'euros la trésorerie de
l'Agence du service civique pour tenir
compte des sous-exécutions ce n'est donc
pas le cas cette année mais voilà je
remercie le sénateur d'être vigilant
effectivement àce qu'on puisse aller
chercher toujours l'argent là où on peut
merci monsieur le ministre de ses
réponses précises et et donc nous examin
dans quelques jours le rapport du
rapporteur des
rapporteurs et peut-être nous déposerons
des des amendement y compris sur la
question de la santé puisque on petit
bémol dans votre expression tout à
l'heure sur la santé
scolaire